[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
sad and spooky
[Laughter]
it's like a ghost is going to come pop
out and get you well you never know you
never know what what might happen on the
show i did it in like literally like 10
minutes yeah like i said i wanted i
didn't you know i didn't know what to do
should i was like should i make it goofy
should i make it it's good because i
know like our on the menu one is like
kind of like do do do do do like happy
but it's like we haven't done it on the
menu for a long time now that i'm
thinking about it no i could we could do
we could do something like that soon
yeah
well we've just been we've actually been
keeping up with the movies so we haven't
because i mean the on the menu show we
just usually do that if we like haven't
watched a movie like and don't have
anything to review i did some rose pork
sitting up there we didn't haven't even
eaten it remember i thought you said it
was i thought you said it was uh
i thought you said it was beef no the
gravy was beef oh okay i gotcha yeah
it's like pot roast well see that's the
thing like i
yeah it's like okay so earlier today
mixing pork and beef oh well
yeah whatever meats meat
it's just
well you had it in there and it's like i
didn't i didn't eat any breakfast i
don't usually um usually the only thing
i'll have a cup of coffee every now and
then i'll have like a cup of yogurt if
i've got some but i don't have any
yogurt left
so i just didn't eat anything
and then
so i went out in the kitchen and he was
like making something he's like yeah i'm
making pot roast or whatever it was she
said and he's like but it's not gonna be
done for a really long time and i'm like
dude i'm like starving right now it's
like
so we just went to publix deli and got
like some chicken chicken chicken and
potato salad yeah so that's what we had
man i look [ __ ] tired on tv okay see
you're here on tv
i'm on a tv on that damn tv
my dad was going to go into surgery
today and they [ __ ] can't oh [ __ ] why
like you didn't replace this little
pacemaker thing they just got sticking
in there it's a it's a wire oh yeah yeah
there was something something his throat
was uh swollen up
so uh they decided they weren't gonna do
it today they're gonna do it at a later
date
because he's got that thyroid cancer
it's not it's not operable it's going so
slowly that he'll be dead by the time
that thing could kill him anyway so
that's not really a threat to his life
yeah so um
i think it had something to do with that
thyroid cancer maybe they were gonna
ventilate him or something
i mean you don't know if they intubate
him
i don't know i would imagine yeah they
probably had to so they didn't want to
do it if you're if yeah i don't know all
the details i just heard that that it
got scrubbed he they sent him back home
oh yeah you didn't tell me yeah i found
out last night that he was going oh but
it's but it's not it's not
life-threatening it's just a really easy
surgery they're just gonna [ __ ] pop a
new
uh pacemaker in there it's basically
just inserting a wire yeah you know and
then it goes in there it's
you know they they can they don't even
have to knock you out to do it nowadays
there's like modern science right yeah
it's like they can do it on twilight
local anesthesia
but you i don't know i i didn't think
they had to intubate for that for some
reason there was some kind of swelling
in his throat they didn't want to do it
maybe it wasn't that maybe it was just
kind of like oh maybe he's got some kind
of infection and we don't like want to
[ __ ] with it or you know i mean it's
always better if you're like
even if it's not a big deal if you're
like gonna be digging around in somebody
like probably better to just like
minimize the risk you know they gonna
put in a new pacemaker
gonna put in more turkey necks
[Laughter]
just some medication keeping me alive
yeah
my dad talked about just medicine
keeping me alive
well you know i don't give a [ __ ]
that's his attitude that's nice wait i'm
gonna die eventually anyway i don't give
a [ __ ] well everybody is i can't do
nothing
he did really yeah that's what he says i
can't do nothing he can't go nowhere i
don't give a [ __ ]
oh he's real positive
he's always looking at the brighter side
just sitting here watching the history
channel [ __ ] this
[Laughter]
yeah
[ __ ]
he watching the mermaid doctor yeah i
still remember i still remember that did
you know that mermaids are real
[Laughter]
what
yeah
i saw
documentary on it had all the scientists
and
everything it's like what the [ __ ] are
you talking about
yeah
they extinct now though
it's like what the [ __ ] okay
history channel said so yeah it's on
history channel was it on history or
discovery that might have been on
discovery yeah yeah when they were
experimenting with it
my dad wasn't it was a good it was a
good mockumentary i gotta say but it was
very obviously a mockingbird
yeah
you know my dad did not come from that
mockumentary gym well yeah not real yeah
that's on tv that should happen yeah not
real culturally savvy yeah no sorry i
was like
did you see saunders name no was i can't
read it sandra is tom's personal back
shaver
[Laughter]
i imported one all the way from germany
yeah i had to pay by the pound
you know what's really funny is that
completely uh coincidentally yeah we
were watching well we watched
witchfinder general last night because
we had to do um we did a review of it
that were that's gonna go up uh tomorrow
if you're a patreon on friday if you're
not yeah uh so we did that and then i
was like man i don't really have to
watch anything else i'm like gonna watch
an old mystery science theater episode
and i picked one that i hadn't seen for
a long time which was the wild wild
world of batwoman
and i had forgotten that on that
particular episode which is from season
five i think
their invention because i don't know if
you know mst they do an invention
exchange at the beginning like it's a
big whole thing uh but their invention
on this one was the razorback and it was
a big giant like razor that you use like
to shape your back yeah that's what i
need
and i was like i didn't even i forgot
that that was the invention on that
episode and i just like laughed and
laughed because i was like holy crap
that's like so coincidental that i chose
that episode yeah
yeah well okay what she's talking about
is like yesterday i was saying that
wasn't yesterday was it or that uh last
time last show when um i can't remember
when i mentioned it was it was not
yesterday but it might have been the day
before yeah yesterday or it might have
been fri i don't remember one what were
you talking about i don't know why would
we we have been talking about shaving
your back like on a show about like a
movie well not like
we we would do that but i was talking
let's talk about having jenny shave my
back she didn't want to do it
well i mean she's i'm busy you know that
kind of [ __ ] i did not
well i just you know i was just kind of
like really oh yeah she really wanted
that's right it was more it was more
kind of like oh my god this is my life
now kind of yeah it's that kind of thing
yeah
that says i'll just [ __ ] import i'll
just import [ __ ] sandra over here
from germany to shave my back i'll have
her back there [ __ ] shaving my back
anytime i want to i'll try to vet you
know i know who sander is i've already
identified her
i figured out who it is oh yeah yeah
i got videos over
um
i tracked it down oh oh you're stalking
her no i just [ __ ] i i i i was on
[ __ ] i was on one of those damn porn
channels and [ __ ] stumbled across her
uh he said that's gotta be sad
i'm gonna show y'all
all right
this show is not safe for work not safe
for human consumption
i should say
that's actually that's that should be
our new tagline that's our new tagline
for the show not safe for you
i'm gonna put that on the next shirt
hold on let me see hugo says you should
do wax
what
that [ __ ] hurts though i can't i don't
even want to do that
or nair but like i said nair kind of
stinks
although they have they have ones
yeah it burns too they have nair now
that doesn't smell as bad because it
used to like smell like rotten eggs yeah
like back in the old days i got some
more recently that
didn't it kind of smelled but didn't
smell like as strongly as it used to but
it still like totally burns and it also
kind of
if you have sensitive skin i wouldn't
really uh advise using it because it'll
give you like a really bad rash yeah i'm
having a problem finding her
i had somebody exactly in mind i found i
said that's got to be sand
you had someone why is my ice melting
already
oh look the sprite is just melting away
i can put some more in look at that [ __ ]
well i was gonna say that you could just
like bring it like like a cup of ice and
i could just like put it in there i
can't show that in the screen we get
we'll get [ __ ]
well you need to find a picture that's
like
like a sensor or you could like put your
finger over like th
the problem areas
or something like that
but yeah we had to go to the store like
i said because we had to get some food
because i was dying but like um we had
to go to the liquor store also because
it's wednesday and you know we were
almost at a booze
and i decided i'm like i'm just i'm not
really down with the whipped cream stuff
anymore it's like it's good but
it's just like a little bit too sweet
for me so i got cherry vodka instead and
then i got like a big like 12-pack of
spray because i like that
i like cherry and sprite together
but for whatever reason
he brings it in and it's like and as
soon as i poured the sprite in like the
ice was like nope
i'm out
and it just all melted
[ __ ] florida man
i just can't i just can't
and now
was that when you brought this glass in
here was that all vodka
no
or had you or had you put some because
you had to put sprite in there but the
sprite wasn't refrigerated oh so
the sprite wasn't cold it was came out
of the closet okay can
sprite came out of the closet it came
out of cloud
was in the closet we didn't know that
about you spray yeah sprite's out of the
closet
now i get it that's it
yeah it took you yeah
it took me a second to understand what
it was you're talking about that's okay
we love everybody yeah
it's probably coming out of the closet
you do you
hey tila's here team decides show up
oh my god taylor i'm uh trying i found
sandra
i'm gonna show you to her
i found i found her only fancy sandra
i'm only on only fans i don't do it for
free
[Laughter]
i just can't find it it was a bootleg
version of it oh okay i got you i'm
trying trying to find the exact one i
was
mr roboto says jenny you two could get
the dollar shave club sponsor we totally
should i feel like cause didn't for a
long time
uh dan bell had
was it dollar shave club though i don't
know if it was dollar shave but it was
something like that yeah and um i always
laughed at his like little commercials
that he made thank you no need for me
too just for just for you guys being you
oh thank you that's a
we don't know how to be anybody else
but yeah so but he would do these little
commercials like him and [ __ ] rick
sarah
and uh
the [ __ ] was like just so so funny uh
honestly he had another sponsor too
that was uh [ __ ] man i can't remember
which one it was but he had a sponsor
that was one of those it was one of
those meal kits you know they send you
the you know a week's worth of food with
like the recipes and everything already
prepared you know like uh
[ __ ] man now i can't even remember what
one of them is called but uh yeah he was
one of those and he did a commercial for
that too and i like that he had his
friend was it brennan
and he had his friend brennan like in
full drag like making the thing yeah
like in this like like with sparkly eye
shadow on it and everything it was
fantastic yeah and i just thought that
was so awesome yeah he actually did look
like a woman and i didn't think that
that dude could look like a woman
yeah if you see him that was brennan
right yeah brendan evangelista yeah
who's on there um
another dirty room i would have known it
was drag queen but i didn't i didn't
expect it you didn't know that it was
brennan i wouldn't know it was him but i
wouldn't expect him to look like that as
a drag queen
yeah it was just funny like they just
had and it was just in like somebody's
apartment and he was just like cooking
the thing and it was just like and he
was all like glammed out it was like
super funny
but yeah
man dan does like the funniest [ __ ]
i love dan dan bell is like i love him
because he's like low-key funny
you know what i mean yeah i don't it's
hard to explain like you can tell that
he's not like like trying to be funny
he's just like really low-key funny and
i don't i don't know how to explain that
any better than that but well she says
he's low he's he
he's executing
he's executing comedy correctly that's
why it's funny yeah okay there's
if you go if you go to a drama school
you'll learn how to execute comedy so
he's just doing it well yeah comedy is
better when it's like natural yeah i
like comedy but it's like natural or
like situational that's why i like
comedians like eddie izzard who
basically just comes out and just like
improvises and tells yeah he doesn't
tell jokes he's just like talking and
he's just but it's funny he's not like
telling jokes he's also drunk he's his
humor is dry yeah yeah yeah all right so
that that's part of it
yeah what was i oh um zach was saying
i'm sad dan bell and will karpinsky from
his old videos don't work together
anymore
yeah i think they um dan won't really go
into it i guess it's like a personal
matter but uh i guess him and will like
had some kind of falling out and they
don't talk anymore i know he kind of
brought that up on some of his newer
because he's put up he's mostly gone
um
he posts most of his [ __ ] on patreon to
be honest i should actually go be a
patron because
i mean it's only like a couple bucks a
month and it's like he's apparently got
like a [ __ ] ton of stuff on there but
every now and then he'll post like one
of his
you know live streams or or a podcast or
something like that on youtube and i
watch them and they're like super super
funny but it's he did kind of bring up
that him and will because i think
somebody asked him about it during a q a
and all he would say was basically like
oh we don't really talk anymore or they
had kind of like a fight but i don't
know about what so
yeah that is kind of like a shame
because i did like that guy
but he hasn't done i like brennan though
and i feel like brennan is mostly he's
the he's canadian
um so
he was on a lot of the another dirty
room episodes and him and rick sarah
when they were both on there that [ __ ]
was [ __ ] funny yeah i still but my
favorite episode still is that one where
they were in that like tiki broom yes
and they both had their like [ __ ]
grass skirts on and they just got like
pretty hammered uh because they always
bring like tons of booze
and a bunch of weed
so it's like usually they're tearing
apart the room and they're like the
room's disgusting and everything that's
fun too although that tiki one wasn't
actually that dirty but it was real
expensive too i think it was like 200
something dollars a night usually they
stay in like some
crack motel
that's like 50 bucks like or 70 bucks
and it's just like a [ __ ] well they
go they go to the worst rated woods yeah
because that does make a more
entertaining show although some of the
shows he did one a while back that was
just like you know the grossest [ __ ]
like top 10 grossest [ __ ] that they
found like in the rooms and i tried to
sit through the whole thing without
gagging and i couldn't do it
oh my god
it was just that kind of stuff just like
grosses me out i don't know how
i don't know how they do that show
without just like vomiting forever
because it's no seriously because if i
was it like it's funny when they do it
and like sometimes dan will be like oh
my god like you can kind of hear him
like going
like that but if it was me i wouldn't be
able to talk because i would just be
gagging and gagging and gagging and i
wouldn't be able to stop because it's
just like so [ __ ] gross like some of
the [ __ ]
like i can deal with
you know finding [ __ ] crack pipes and
crusty underwear and
blood and stuff like that but like
sometimes they pull off the matter they
flip over the mattress and it's just
like
diarrhea stains and like [ __ ] yeah
yeah just i'm just like crack coat i'm
like no
i just can't watch it they're crack
hotels and they're just like in the
worst part of town oh and they have they
have uh bed bugs lots of them have bed
bugs
and it's just yeah and what's funny is
that
it's a crack hotel
it's on the wrong side of town but they
still want 40 or 50 bucks for that
[ __ ] room
it's like dude that's what i'm saying
it's like god you should pay me
here for [ __ ] sake
wouldn't even spend 15 to go in there
you couldn't even take a hooker in there
you get [ __ ] bed bugs
yeah it's like you know is it as if you
didn't already have enough problems in
your life yeah you have to stay in this
then you take you take bed bugs back to
your house
yeah yeah and you can't get rid of that
everybody knows that those [ __ ] get
in your house man
tila is asking what favorite comedians
are like in general like i said i
already mentioned eddie izzard he's
probably my favorite comedian
like in the more
recent ones although i mean you know
he's been going a long time but he's
still around
um i don't know
i can't find who i was looking for
and the shit's acting real glitchy
so
you just guys just have to use your
imagination
this whole time he's like looking he's
this is excuse me i was going by and i'm
going to like look at porn
i was going like
there's sandra
that's gotta be sandra
yeah
holy [ __ ]
tila said stayed in something similar
when i had to vacate an old apartment
years ago
next door was a prostitute turning
tricks across the street was an all-day
baptist church yeah yeah you know it's
bad you know the neighborhood is sucking
in decline
when you've got crack hotels
churches and pawn shops that's just
check cashing check cash in places that
means that that is a shrinking
population the high mortality and
laundromats yeah laundry bats i kind of
feel like that's another thing that's
all associated with liquor storage it's
not going good
yeah they're selling off all their
possessions they're dying
they're in the crack hotels
they don't have running water at the
house
so they can't even wash the damn dishes
they can't even wash the clothes in the
sink so they're going to go to
laundromat
yeah they don't have washer dryers it's
really sad well it's safe to wash your
dryer but it's been broken for 10 years
it's sad because i kind of feel like i
mean a lot of the places they stay in
are like disgusting and stuff and it's
like yeah a lot of people are like drug
addicts and they go in there to shoot up
and stuff like that but
some people like don't i mean you can't
afford to stay anywhere better than that
and it's just kind of like
you know
there's just no reason anybody should
stay in those conditions seriously in
this day and age i mean it's just so
there's nowhere for them to go that's
what i mean but that's like it's just
sad because it's like [ __ ] usually
what it was is they were on the
periphery to begin with in the service
economy uh that made money off of uh off
of an industry like a like a fabrication
industry like the car industry or things
related to that all that [ __ ] went
overseas to china
so the service industries around it
we're no longer needed they all go on
welfare and then it gets scrimpier and
scrimpier and then all the money gets
sucked out of the state and that
particular state can't pay the welfare
the feds jump in they pay some and it's
just
it's just on life support but they're
reducing the population it
takes a couple generations that's the
thinking that's what they're thinking
but what they they well [ __ ] they said
it they said it during this pandemic
many times over they just what they call
people um
non-essential personnel
people that aren't needed they don't
make money off you
yeah zach says my roommate lived in a
place with bed bugs real bad back in
cali and has scars all over his back
because of it he refuses to go swimming
because of it too yeah i mean bed bugs
are like the [ __ ] worst and they're
really um hard to get out yeah i mean
dan bellen has when they do the show
they have like all the [ __ ] like they
have all this you know luminol like to
test for blood they have all the drug
tests [ __ ] so they can tell like if they
find something like what it is um you
know they have like the the black light
all that kind of stuff um
but they're very very you know they have
gloves and tweezers and everything like
that they're really um careful about bed
bugs because yeah you get those you
can't get rid of them um i'm talking
about comedians dj maniac says i grew up
on carlin and pryor yeah they're awesome
also bill hicks is awesome uh i also dig
pat oswalt yeah he's [ __ ] funny david
cross i love him too i haven't seen like
a lot of his stuff i think i saw like
one of his specials a few years back and
it was [ __ ] hilarious i've heard of
brian postne but i don't think i've
heard i've seen a lot of his stuff
um
yeah where oh uh zach says
i've been listening to an audiobook
about marilyn monroe and my god was her
life tragic i think she'd make a real
interesting show topic you know i never
thought of that but that's actually like
a good idea we did do like
a hollywood one but i don't think we
talked about her on there did we did we
i think we did like hollywood mysteries
or hollywood murders or something like
that zach's also saying we ought to do a
show about gary indiana that's another
[ __ ]
city that vanished off the face of
nothing that one went down worse than
detroit it was smaller than detroit yeah
it was one of the it was one of the
cities that supported detroit it was on
the same rail
railroad uh system
and uh a bunch of bad [ __ ] happened
there over the years and it just it's
just a crumbling it's ruins the downtown
area
there's guys that do it yeah they do
exploration
all the bed and theaters all abandoned
churches
they're go you know they'll take some
awesome
footage in there
they were just real nice buildings at
one time
but you have to think of what the
situation was in the early 1900s late
1800s
they didn't really know how economies
worked there was no implosion or
explosion of economies none of that was
really considered
if they built something they built it in
the 1800s fashion which was like they're
built to last made of bricks
so whenever they opened a factory they
they acted like that thing would be
there for 150 200 years doing what it
did yeah yeah we're gonna make model a's
for a hundred years
and it didn't really work out that way
so that's why nowadays when they build a
city it's
built out of real light materials
because
they'll build a building and it's only
there for a few decades and then tear it
down
nothing's permanent
and uh
yeah because can you imagine like in the
1800s they'd be like this typewriter
factory will be here forever yeah at the
time and we're going to build a whole
town around this typewriter factory and
everyone in town will work on that so
like i said always good
it just well just kind of like in any
like city planning and any kind of just
like your stock portfolio it's always
good to diversify because you never know
how shit's going to come and go so any
kind of town that was built around i saw
this some back
in the 90s in um you know in the uk like
in wales and stuff because a lot of
those smaller towns were built entirely
around a coal mine and when the coal
mines closed everybody went out of work
uh so you know so there was a lot of
poverty and stuff they've actually like
to you know a lot of them bounce back
now but you can kind of see
how that could happen where it's like
everybody in the town worked at the coal
mine in some capacity and then when
that's not there anymore
everyone's just kind of like left yeah
tina's talking about up and she's up in
california saying yeah nothing is
permanent i know
nothing is permanent wildfire is burning
this [ __ ] down
um yeah everything's temporary and
everything's much more fragile than you
think it is
and the more advanced the civilization
becomes the more complicated and fragile
it becomes because it's the systems laid
upon systems laid upon systems laid upon
systems you go in there and you can
remove a sector of the economy and the
whole thing can just start going wonky
and um
you know the united states doesn't
really make anything anymore so if a
global trade system breaks down because
of a war with i don't know who
maybe a country like china if you go to
war with china
then uh
all of a sudden you just starved of
every all the necessities you [ __ ]
need we're totally dependent on them
it's too late
you know it'd take 10 years
to get free of them probably
and uh and that's gonna happen they
could topple us in a heartbeat they've
slowly played the damn chinese finger
trap game
uh
they played the long game
my prognosis for the united states as a
union is not good
i think it'll go back to a federal
system like like a federation
and then maybe that may not last too
long then new federations will emerge
there's just too many damn conflicting
ideologies too many enemies inside the
united states you know americans [ __ ]
basically hate each other
and it's just uh
it's everything that's happened with
afghanistan and just everything that's
how it's unfolding
everything that the federal government
says
it's just uh
it's looking like
an unraveling empire and it just you
look through history this is what it
looks like
and afghanistan is nicknamed the
graveyard of empires everybody who went
in there including the british their
empire was gone [ __ ]
only a few years after the russians
alexander
and it's not anything crazy it's not
luck or anything it's not a curse it's
when the world sees you
lose a fight against such a primitive
enemy all of a sudden nobody fears you
so everybody turns on you and all your
enemies turn on you and you're
you're eaten by fleas basically the
civilization is eaten by cockroaches
because uh
most of an empire is built upon
coercive force and if you don't have any
way to coerce someone using force then
you don't have an empire
the value of your money declines [ __ ]
people start investing in other empires
and uh people start saying [ __ ] you and
they don't listen to you i predict the
next thing to have in china will take
taiwan once and we will do nothing
and when people see that it's gonna be
like rats leaving the sinking ship all
the money and everything will go to
china and they've planted this they've
planned this out
they knew exactly what they were doing
thank you victor
jenny you got my eddie hazard reference
reference in overtime last show yeah i
caught that and then i was like i had
already like pushed the button like to
stop the stream and i was like oh [ __ ] i
can't let that [ __ ] slide uh tammy
said there's a show on netflix called
serpent
which is about a serial killer in the
70s killing backpackers in thailand
see now that sounds like right up my
alley i've never heard of that so i just
wrote it down
so you know we'll we'll see uh roger
dodger says netflix annoys me why why is
that necessary i mean i can see why it's
like a big giant
thing but i don't know they got some
good [ __ ] on there it's it's a mixed bag
just like anything else yeah and
honestly um you have to have more than
one streaming service honestly um i have
shutter i have netflix shutter amazon
prime yeah and hulu and then plus
there's free [ __ ] like you know pluto tv
2b
um and between that
out there you know you can find most
anything even sometimes like if you have
to go to like youtube or amazon prime
and like rent something if you you know
it's only like 2.99 to 3.99 to rent it
then i can see pretty much anything i
want to see for under five dollars so
i'm good with that yeah john's saying
there's no real way to defend taiwan
anymore yeah exactly
taiwan is going to have to sink the swim
it's unfortunate because if you ask me
taiwan is the rightful china
they're the only ones that preserve the
damn culture they have all the damn
cultural stuff i think that's why
china wants it
is because they have they when they left
they
took a lot of real important cultural
artifacts with them
and and then
you know
the chinese mainland [ __ ] destroyed
all their cultural artifacts during
their revolution so you know they were
trying to get rid of everything that was
old including the people
so you know
it's going to end bad thank you david
june little shop of horrors
retrospective do you want to see the
original one or the 80s one
uh we could because i like them both
honestly we could um
i don't know we could do one with both
of them maybe
uh because i've actually the 80s one i
saw a million times when i was a kid
dexter came back
yeah we needed to quit like start
watching that okay dj maniac says i just
binged brand new cherry flavor on
netflix this weekend i just saw that
come up and i saw the trailer and that
looks pretty good
uh he says it's out there
all right that sounds like a
recommendation i might have to watch
that though that's a series right it's
not like a movie
because i just like saw the thing when i
was like scrolling through
sandra i will never watch dexter again i
was so angry about the ending
but they had to end the scene i could
see why people were pissed off but it
didn't bother me that much honestly i
was just kind of like
all right i think they kind of got the
information that it would that they were
ending in short notice wasn't it
i think they had to it might have been i
mean it's kind of hard
i don't know like like i said you know i
watch a lot of horror i read a lot of
horror and that seems to be like a a
constant problem in horror and in like
series and stuff like that is like it's
hard to end stuff in a way that's going
to satisfy everybody and i think with a
series that's probably the worst because
like you said you never know
is this going to be the last season you
know what i mean so should we just like
try to stick the landing and it's going
to be this big fabulous thing um that
you know that builds on everything and
everyone's going to be satisfied which
they never are because they never are
about anything but the worst was the
walking dead
well it didn't end it just slowly
started to fizzle and just it's still on
yeah i know it just and actually it has
a couple of like um offshoot shows as
well now
that are still going uninteresting and
just so but honestly like i said a
series goes on for so long it's like
you've done everything it's like what
else are you gonna do with it so it's
just gonna keep on going and it's like
it's still making money so they still
want to like keep it on but it's just
kind of like what the [ __ ] what more can
we do with this you know what i mean
it's like there's only so much you can
do
it got pretty damn hard like around
season three or four and they could
should have kept going in that direction
but started to soften up and become
fantasy
and just like come on
you know i mean it lost that survival
horror
element yeah yeah but like i said kind
of like survivor right people that were
getting just killed and you had to have
people get killed in every [ __ ] but
realistically from a realistic
standpoint you know if that really
happened in real life
um you know it wouldn't be like that
forever like there would be some kind of
like little pockets of you know people
starting to farm and [ __ ] like that so
it would go more like that direction so
it's kind of like
i don't know i feel like you with a
series like that you can't really win
because it's like if it goes in the
direction of oh now we're like building
communities again you know people be
like oh that's boring
but then if you like go in a direction
of now it's just constant zombie
fighting that would also get boring so
it's kind of like you can't win like
whatever you do i don't know i think i
could keep because i'll be fighting
pretty interesting
sorry i just saw another eddie izzard
reference from pixar walking to just
slowly collapse like a flan and a
cupboard yeah
now okay tila says honestly i've never
viewed an episode of dexter are we
rooting for a serial killer does it work
yeah yes but
but
uh he only kills other serial killers he
doesn't kill innocent people and it's
all explained
how he became that way and he's so
[ __ ] likable yeah he's a serial
killer he's not normal
but he was raised by a law enforcement
officer who figured out what he was
and who knew that he had that proclivity
and he he couldn't change it so he got
him to
modify his behavior to go after other
serial killers
so he and he works in like he's a blood
spatter yes he works in law enforcement
so he's getting his leads through
so yeah so when he finds a person he
goes to like great lengths to
know like is this the guys this you know
this guy did this that and the other
okay well i'm i'm gonna go after this
guy and then like he hunts a different
one every season yeah it's actually
really really good so like i said he's
it's got good humor and it's a florida
series it's all about here in florida as
you can see it's in miami yeah i think
miami it's got a little got a lot of
good uh cuban characters in it it's a
good it's it's a good series and like i
said michael c hall is just such a
likable dude yeah that
i mean it's really and he's only killing
bad people
like other people like himself like so
because he figures who better to hunt a
serial killer than someone who knows who
is a serial killer
yeah he's a vigilante he's almost kind
of like batman in a way he is kind of
yeah kinda but you do see him kind of
like struggle yeah uh you know with his
with his serial killerness
uh so you know that's kind of where a
lot of the tension in the show comes
from but like i said it's i don't want
to say it's lighthearted because it's
not no but he has fun though it does
have a lot of dark humor in it which i
like i like stuff with like that gallows
kind of humor hannibal lecter kind of
did that too
hannibal electric killed people who
insulted him people who were rude who
were rude yeah people who were people
free-ranging
he killed them you know you know he was
that was a good character too um yeah i
really liked uh
hannibal hannibal rises the the thank
you again victor pretty cool that was
good he laughed because i got the eddie
izzard references
[Laughter]
seriously i've seen
dress to kill and like all his old
specials like so many times that i think
i have them like [ __ ] memorized at
this point
dexter could have ended better says no
need for me too walking dead uh f the
story big time killing carl uh yep
spoiler alert that was like several
seasons ago although carl pissed me off
so i wasn't mad that they killed him uh
comics said that they kept people alive
for too long
yeah i think that was like a complaint
that some people yeah they kept people
alive too long then they obviously
started to like pander
to uh diversity and [ __ ] and and adding
characters just because their sexual
orientation and just you know you could
see that there was they were trying to
not paint a realistic world of [ __ ]
apocalyptic mayhem but they were trying
to just
please everybody and that's not the way
an apocalypse would be it
it happened that was good like season
three
when you were just pissed off
you know what i mean i'm frustrated
because
the characters are getting killed
they're going insane they're making
[ __ ] up
decisions
rick's hallucinating because he's damn
crazy uh nobody trusts each other that's
that's when that show was the best
or then when his when his friend
when his friend started going after his
woman remember like and that was season
two
rick's friend what was his name yeah
yeah shane shane yeah the shang
character was fantastic shane slowly
going into a damn
ruthless psychopath you know and he was
like you guys are behind you don't see
the way the world really is now you know
and then he almost joined the bad guys
because he's like uh these people are
going to make it
that was pretty good though it was just
good writing
you know
but as it went on the writing got bad it
got
disneyfied like disney well like i said
it seemed like they just kind of ran out
of ideas they ran out ideas and then
they just started to just pander
pander to the audience and
and pander to twitter you know what i
mean and it's just all right come on
and then and then they [ __ ] up they
[ __ ] up um
what was what was that character's name
of the heroes here
morgan morgan yeah because the morgan
character was fantastic he went to fear
the walking dead i think yeah he
morgan was fantastic but he was only
fantastic when he was insane
well yeah insane people are way more
interesting yeah as soon as he started
softening him and making him say and
they're like ah
then he wasn't interesting anymore
morgan was great when he [ __ ] jumped
on your ass with that damn face plate
and a body armor with guns and [ __ ]
shooting people here's not here here's
not here you know just [ __ ] says
here's not here
yeah yeah and what else would he say he
just had he had all these little sayings
that he would say to keep himself sane i
don't remember a ball
uh here's not here is one of them yeah i
remember that i don't know it's been a
long time
like i said we watched it pretty much
every we watched like the first like six
or seven seasons like all the time i
kind of feel like after glenn got killed
against spoiler alert um
that kind of like i i like that they had
the balls to do that because glenn was
like one of my favorite characters but
then kind of after that i don't know it
just kind of
made me mad and then like when rick like
disappeared
or you know they thought he died right
or something like that it's like i don't
know i liked rick and it's like i just
felt like the show wasn't as good
without him
um you know daryl was still there carol
was still there as far as i know they
still are um you know those two are
awesome characters too but i feel like
they were underutilized i felt like
after a time i just felt like i know
that they were trying to expand the
world out and i know that comics did
that too but it's just kind of like i
felt like there were too many characters
and so you couldn't
focus on because i felt like early there
weren't that many characters so you
could like care about the one like the
handful that there were the more they
try to expand the world out and it's
like you know we can only have two
minutes with this character in two
minutes with that character you can't
develop a relationship with that
character so i think it was more a case
of
them just trying to like put too many
people into this [ __ ] series and you
have to like spread your
your care between all these people and
it's like i couldn't you know i couldn't
establish the same kind of like feelings
about the ones that i had established
early on because they didn't have that
many at first yeah people are mentioning
things yeah carol became like an
unstoppable force which that sucked
um that she didn't have any weaknesses
um and then like they had they had some
really good characters um
who were
real kind of groundbreaking um merle
murrah was a really well written
character i understand why merle had to
die
but there could have been more mural in
there well because that was an impetus
too for like daryl daryl's kind of
journey you know what i mean i think it
would have been better it would have
been it had been
better if merle was presumed dead and
just and just
disappeared
you know maybe maybe you find him later
there's a bunch of [ __ ] that you could
tell they changed writers because they
were going to do certain things
but it never came to fruition
daryl said he saw a chupacabra he said
he know he knew what was real
they never got around to what the i
thought they were going to do more and
actually wasn't i think the name of that
episode was chupacabra so i thought that
they were going to do something with
that and that was one of the best that
was one of the best like they were gonna
like it was gonna come to pass that like
a deformed
dog or monkey or something was like
started like the zombie epidemic yeah
which would have been a good callback
but i think they found a weapon escape
thing you know what i mean well like i
said it's like you know they have a team
of writers and it's kind of like they
try to like maintain uh continuity
obviously uh because they know how
people are nowadays and everyone's like
super nitpicky but you have like a
different set of writers every time you
know which i don't think they
necessarily did i think there was like a
lot of the same ones but you're gonna
like have people bringing stuff in and
and like i said the more characters you
have the more plot threads you have the
more plot threads you have the more that
some of them are going to get short
shrift or they're just going to get
forgotten about so i do kind of feel
like
i don't know i feel like a series in
some ways like i said it's kind of
damned if you do and damned if you don't
because
you know if it goes on a long time if
it's really successful and people want
to see more of it you feel like oh well
i have to expand this universe out which
generally means adding more characters
or adding more locations or blah blah
but it's like the more you do that the
more likely it is that people are going
to lose that connection they had to the
original characters because there's too
many and it's like spread too thin so i
kind of feel like that's sort of what
happened in that in that case yeah but
carol becoming an unstoppable force
didn't make sense it'd be make more
sense that morgan would be an
unstoppable force because he was
surviving on his own [ __ ] crazy for
so long
and his aggressive he could turn a whole
town into a kill zone
and a big trap for people that made more
sense thank you dom the bomb what do you
say uh the ladies the latest series
really changes things up jumping seven
years ahead made things much better it's
almost like the comic but enough
difference which ended two years ago
yeah i actually uh to be honest i
haven't read the comics like i know
generally what happens in them because
i've read like synopsis but i haven't
read them
um
morgan also said some stuff
that they never that they never followed
through with
when uh rick found him in that town that
he turned into his kill zone
into his trap he said something about i
don't you know you don't know me and you
remember you don't know me and then he
said i saw you and you were dead
you had you had a dead man's face
yeah you know and they never really
picked up on it he and i thought when he
was talking about that i thought he was
talking about the whispers i was
thinking but then the whispers didn't
come along until like several seasons
later which i was like oh finally here
they are i thought he was talking about
that yeah i saw you and you had a dead
man's face
and yeah
like he was wearing a dead man's face
and they you know
they should have picked they should have
handed it at that a long you know just a
few episodes into it
they should have talked about i saw a
man with a dead man's face you know
they
yeah because like there would have been
these groups like p you would have like
heard about it like through the great
valley
run before you saw them right yeah tla
was saying uh the terminus group yeah
the cannibals they should have done more
with that there would have been more
groups like that
yeah is daryl still in the show i think
so as far as i know does he still do his
motorcycle show because i actually quite
like that i don't watch tv anymore yeah
see i don't know i haven't heard
anything about it but you know yeah i
don't ever look at cable so i don't know
but i did like his motorcycle like kind
of road trip show yeah in extreme
societal collapse like what happened in
china's cultural revolution cannibalism
was common same thing in the same thing
in russia as it went through collapses
and especially during world war ii on
the eastern front people don't realize
how common cannibalism was
you push comes to shove people eat each
other especially if there's a bunch of
dead people lying around in the snow
that [ __ ] gets eaten well like i said
it's meat you don't waste it they don't
waste anything they don't need it
anymore i mean you know not to be an
[ __ ]
in a situation like a zombie apocalypse
there'd be a lot of cannibals
yeah you'd think that yeah i mean like i
said just out of necessity is that a
necessity and i think a lot of people
wouldn't even do it like you know
because there's much of it there'd be
enough dead people laying around that
you could probably just well if they're
fighting over supplies or something the
dead are just recycled yeah it's not
like you're doing it to eat people it's
just that
fighting is always going to result in
casualties yeah you're and this is the
way it was
and like i said it's not like people are
going to be like mean spirited about it
it's like we're not going to go out and
you know kill people but if you get
killed then we're going to eat you right
and
if it's somebody on your team then
you're going to say well it's an honored
tradition that we have well yeah and
some cultures didn't have that so it's
like you know and and i can totally see
that point of view the enemy they
explained it as i'm going to absorb my
enemy's strength yeah yeah
uh can you really have walking dead
without daryl probably not but that's
the thing like daryl now has plot armor
because everybody everybody knows how
much nor i mean and that's and i
understand that because i also love
norman reedus and i don't and the show
would not be the same without him but
you don't so but you can't but that's
the thing you get to a point where like
a character is so beloved that you know
that nothing's gonna happen but you
don't have to kill the character get
them off the show yeah they can just be
lost presumed dead
although i kind of hate when they do
that yeah well you could bring them back
dude that was like a glenn under the
dumpster moment yeah you know what i
mean
because that's that's kind of the rule
on the walking dead and honestly like on
most series if you don't see the person
die like right up in your face then you
know they're still alive and they're
gonna pop in at some opportune moment
somewhere prepper pov says what is the
best cut of meat on a human
probably rub let's see if any cannibals
let's see if any cannibals in the
comments like it's always the same for
animals yeah i mean you would think it's
gonna be romp and die right where the
like all the marbled fat is yeah we're
talking about eating well it's bigger
that's dahmer he'll tell you
i think he said he liked hands didn't he
said the hands were like bacon
i can't see how hands would taste good
because i guess i got this they just
feel like it's like a chicken wing yeah
i don't know
dip it in some [ __ ] ranch dressing or
some blue cheese with some celery sticks
[ __ ]
good
chinese
fresh banquet and it'll come up
in the 80s the chinese communist
revolutionaries were eating people for
being capitalists they were [ __ ]
hungry it's when they got into eating
bugs and [ __ ] that's how [ __ ] hungry
they got
during the cultural revolution
flesh banquet
they just give it a name and [ __ ]
denouncing a [ __ ] as a
capitalist and then eating him
sandra says rick was only lost not dead
right did he show up again i don't know
if he did um i hadn't heard that he had
shown back up on the show but yeah i
think he
i think it was kind of a thing where he
was like presumed dead but they wanted
maybe he wanted the option like to come
back if he wanted to because i think he
was [ __ ] sick of being on that show
because it's been it had been such a
long time and he's been a long time in
the room
and plus he'd been getting typecast and
he probably wanted to do some other [ __ ]
like
coral you know doing the damn accent and
[ __ ] he got sick of that and yeah i
think i think he could see that the
writing was starting to suffer the
writing was bad sorry people the writing
got bad at least and when i stopped
watching it well yeah like i said they
like i said it felt like they didn't
really know what to do yeah and it was
just mandarin there was too many too
many characters i think was was the
problem i had uh sandra said guys did
you notice that the stream hasn't
crashed for weeks that's because yeah
it's we got the new computer yeah that's
why
so it must have been like the old
license i still have the old laptop
there that was also like a new laptop
but it wasn't i guess it didn't have
enough uh memory yeah victor says hand
burgers are good mmm hamburgers
uh
zach says this is a good question
if if you guys had to make a dish out of
each other because of cannibalism
raisins what would you make
[Laughter]
i'm gonna make like some tom
butter chicken
damn just out of your butt
[Laughter]
when kiss my ass really mean so thanks
i mean man the cannibalism jokes are
super fun they're kind of like you know
they're kind of dad jokes but that's
okay
tammy says they're making movies to
explain what happened to rick yeah
because i know that
it's not just walking dead there's a
whole like extended universe because
they have like a couple of offshoot
shows i think they have a web series is
that even still on
um i know they had one for a time so
they have like all of this
uh you know uh related lore
that you watch that tells about all this
different stuff which like i said you
get to a you get to a story that's
sprawling
you're gonna have to have all of these
supplemental
materials
to like fill in everybody's [ __ ] because
it's just like there's too many people
you know what i mean they i guess they
have a hardcore fan following but i
think just the kind of the general you
know i watched it it's just i just got
sick of it
you know yeah i mean obviously there's a
lot of people are still watching it
because it's still on if no one was
still watching i mean they've canceled
they they've cancelled shows that were
seemingly more popular than that so
there must like still be the numbers i
just felt that it was it was
bullshitting me you know i mean they
were pulling that [ __ ] out of their ass
and it wasn't really all that well
written and they just got
tired of watching it tired of waiting
for
something to things to happen that never
really did happen and there's just you
know
there's just a lot of weirdness in the
way that that [ __ ] was written now
everybody's talking about cannibalism
jokes yeah
what does a stoner and a necrophiliac
have in common they both like eating
cold tacos
cannibals don't eat clowns because they
taste funny i've heard that one actually
i think my dad told me that one
so that's a literal gadget
or my grandpa might have told me that
i kind of feel like maybe
[Laughter]
there's a reason for dad jokes
i mean everybody knows dad jokes
i was
i was thinking about dad jokes today
because
you remember i told you guys about that
channel because i know some of you have
seen it before uh what's her name jade
the libra and she does like halloween
[ __ ] all the time she does like
halloween decor hunting and you know
cleaning her bathroom or whatever and
she's like decorating for halloween and
she had a video
i think it's fairly recent i think it's
just from like a few weeks ago
and she went halloween decor hunting
with [ __ ]
voltaire
because i guess her and her husband are
like friends with voltaire and voltaire
was playing in kansas city because he's
on tour because i did a poster for the
show that he's doing in tampa or
whatever
and um so he was in kansas city doing a
show and i guess uh he was hanging out
with her and her husband who i think is
a bartender
and uh then the next day him and her
went all around because her thing like
she'll do like a decor hunting video
it's like so it'll be like a week and
she'll drive around all these places
usually like you know michael's or
joanne's or something like that and she
just like goes around like filming all
the halloween [ __ ] that they have and
like sometimes she buys it and like
she'll put it up in her house and
everything but it was just like i
haven't finished watching it yet because
it's like an hour and a half long but
her and voltaire in the car just like
shooting the [ __ ] is so [ __ ] funny
if you don't know who voltaire is
aurelio voltaire
um
he started out
as well he's still a musician
he wrote like it's goth songs but
they're funny and um he's super funny
and he actually has like a really good
voice and stuff too but like then later
he also wrote these little books about
like goth decorating like decorating
your house and stuff and now apparently
for several years he has a youtube
channel that's all like about goth decor
and he just shows gives you like all
these decorating tips and i think he
does his own like halloween decor
hunting videos as well which i didn't
know and i'm like oh my god i have to go
[ __ ] subscribe to that because i'm
sure that's really entertaining but uh
yeah so it was just like funny like
watching them the two of them in the car
for like
an hour like going around [ __ ]
bicycles and stuff
going look at this little bowl with the
bats in it
tom is asking what conan said about the
meaning of life
they asked conan i said conan what's the
meaning of life and he goes to crush
your enemies
to see them driven before you
and to hear the lamentations of their
women i gave him a t-shirt that said
that on the back so it has conan on the
front that it says that on the back [ __ ]
them up
see them running off hear their women
crying all right that's
the meaning of life what is best in life
win that's what it just it just means to
win
yeah
that's true winning is best
much better than losing
winning
[Laughter]
the other dude
dude sun says oh wind in your hair an
eagle at your breast and the [ __ ]
exagna
looking conan what's best [ __ ] [ __ ] up
see him run win yeah that's it
i'll just take a nice cocktail and a
steak thanks yeah
i don't really have to win to get that i
don't really need all that you have to
win you get that though well i don't
know it depends you have to be making
money winning is making money same thing
win
if you were losing you wouldn't have
money for it
okay that's what he's talking about tila
says target always has great halloween
decor just saying they do actually
although i can't remember where it was
because i've been like kind of sometimes
i'll have her videos going on in the
background
and uh
so i watched a bunch from like last year
and she and i can't remember where she
was but i don't think it was target i
think it might have been
home goods or at home or somewhere like
that and they had a whole line
of halloween stuff that was all like
a fortune teller and ouija board and
tarot based and that [ __ ] was beautiful
and they had like a whole line of it
they had like pillows and like they had
all kind of different [ __ ] and just like
the design was really cool like whoever
designed that line
that's that was like some awesome [ __ ]
right there and it was it was [ __ ] that
was like that you could put in your
house all you i'm not saying you can't
put halloween decorations your house all
year long because you totally can but
i'm just saying that it wasn't
it's like it looks spooky but it doesn't
look like halloweeny you know what i'm
saying like you can have it in your
house like all the time but yeah it was
like really nice looking
yeah t uh voltaire is like uh
one of my best friend's uh ex-husband
yeah yeah
girl named tanya he used to yeah he was
gonna seem like a nice dude well you
were he was here i didn't know him
during that time though yeah he was him
after he was here uh he did a show here
like probably a couple of years ago yeah
and i think he can he came to ibar after
and yeah you were talking to him
yeah everybody sees says he seems like a
nice dude i mean in that video he seems
like a totally nice he seems really nice
and i love that i love
now i'm gonna have to go like watch all
his [ __ ] halloween decor i have his
little i have his books about like goth
decorating yeah um but
well he has one
i think he has one that's like a goth
primer like how to be goth like just
kind of like you know here's here's what
you need to know like here's how to do
the drag here's the music and everything
but they're just these little bitty like
hardback books but he has one about um
decorating your house too and apparently
he has like a whole youtube channel
which i previously did not know about so
i'm gonna have to go watch those now
because i'm sure that's really
entertaining apparently he has
uh an apartment in new york city and
then he also has an apartment in mexico
city
um
so
because he was saying that i guess his
girlfriend or wife or whoever um when
they were out looking for halloween [ __ ]
he said i was really disappointed
because well not disappointed he didn't
use that word but um he's like because
his wife girlfriend whoever was like
super into
like the more country looking halloween
stuff and he was just like oh no i'm not
having this in my [ __ ] apartment i
just like showed him
so he's like you can put that in the
mexico city one i'm not having that my
cool like new york apartment no mr
roboto i don't think uh goths especially
young goths i don't think they even know
what a water bed is
i haven't seen a water bed in a really
long time if you if you said water bed
they probably didn't know what you were
talking about yeah they're like water
beds they're right is that like water
board yeah
[Laughter]
they wouldn't even know what you're
talking about
[Laughter]
i remember
i think the last time i saw a water bed
was like when maybe when i was
high school yeah like maybe when i was
in high school like my friend had one
um at her house but
i don't know i kind of i felt like i had
one for like secondhand from somebody
for a long time but it's i didn't like
it because it's just
one
every time you moved it's like
and i was just like i don't like that
too much uh but also it springs leaks
and like chicken and i've had several of
them [ __ ] but they never look they
never leaked well like i said the one
the one i had was second hand so that's
okay so it was like probably they tended
to be cheap they were cheaper than a bot
than a box spring mattress for a while
especially if you're out in california
they were real popular
you could keep them heated they had a
heater in the bottom of them um but they
were inexpensive and they were
comfortable you could sleep on them real
well i couldn't
yeah i just felt like every time i moved
i was like ah i had a bunch of different
kinds some of them had things in so they
wouldn't do that yeah waveless ones
um but you just filled it up
filled it up with a garden hose man yeah
i remember i remember that yeah and um
just
put it
you could pre-heat them that's what was
nice about them
when they were new but they you got sick
of them
they were easy to move though
because you get all the water and they
got small yeah you can just roll that
[ __ ] up
although now take the box
nowadays though um they sell those
mattresses that will like roll up and
they just put them in a box and then
like you bring the box to your house and
then it goes and it just like pops out
and then you can like roll it back up
you know what i mean because like i said
we're living in the [ __ ] future so
you don't need a water bed but yeah i
did used to have one and i had a friend
that had one but i'm sure they still
sell them because they still sell
everything somewhere but
i don't know i feel like that was more
like a 70s thing like oh we're making
waves on the bed baby it was that kind
of [ __ ] uh somebody asked if we were in
the kiss army
that was like so
kiss was just third grade yeah
kiss was so um
what's the word i'm looking for
cheesy yeah but not nervous not in a
good way the purpose of kiss was to sell
lunch boxes pretty much i think my
brother had a kiss lunch box it was
really little
we didn't like kiss we just thought it
looked cool that was gene simmons yeah
gene simmons was intelligent he realized
that you didn't really have to have
really good albums you just needed one
good song on an album and you had to
have a badass album cover the rest of it
you can just [ __ ] a ton of merch yeah
[ __ ] ton of merch
and that's what kiss did
kiss sold merchandise
just kiss lunch boxes
shirts and skateboards and [ __ ] like
that and they
leased all that [ __ ] out to companies
that would do it and they got royalties
yeah they were pretty clever with that
exactly with that branding thing they
were pretty they were pretty far ahead
of the curve on that yeah and you didn't
even
really have to tour you could just sit
back and make money
you know and everything every the kiss
was completely scammified i mean that
was just a [ __ ] scam
like they put out four albums in a year
each guy had his own album and they all
sucked and each one
each album had one good song on it and
so when you added them all together it
was kind of like an ep with the [ __ ]
and they had to make it so it was
collectible i remember that year that
they did that they must have been 77 i
think
and there was like i think somebody said
you know that one song on the peter
chris album is pretty good the rest of
that shit's all [ __ ] it all it all
sucked
remember that
i do i wasn't like i wasn't super into
kiss so i don't really know i knew that
was i but i was like everybody in the
third grade was into that [ __ ] [ __ ]
you know they were their older brothers
were buying all that and painting that
[ __ ] on the side of their love vans and
[ __ ] airbrush and [ __ ] you know but
it was more of a
fashion statement than anything else i
think most people realized that most
kiss songs sucked but they were good
they were great live evidently
well yeah i mean it was like a big
spectacle to see so that i feel like
they probably put more of their effort
into that than actually like writing
decent songs because they feel like hey
if we have like a bunch of lasers and
like [ __ ] blowing up and everything like
that no one will care what the [ __ ]
sounds like plus everyone would be like
super drunk or high so you know you can
get away with stuff i got a feeling they
didn't write songs i think they bought
yeah i don't think they did either i
think they lost
[Laughter]
much easier yeah well i mean there are
like whole teams of guys that just like
sit around and it's like well they don't
they don't have the looks to be rock
stars but they can write songs so they
just kind of sit around like write songs
though and so they can just like sell
them to the highest bidders like hey
give this one to this person this one
that person
i was just you know what i was just
thinking the other day maniac said ace
freely had the only song that charted
out of the solo albums okay yeah ms
minnie's i was thinking it was peter
chris but yeah he's free that's right
yeah i do you remember that when i was a
kid i had and are you talking about like
[ __ ] all the merch that they had
first i don't know how i ended up with
this i didn't buy it or anything but uh
because i was a kid but you remember
like view master
like kids are like what the [ __ ] is a
few master that thing that you know you
put up to your eyes and goes to change
and it has like the 3d pictures in it uh
i had one of those
of kiss
who how did i get that
who gave me that
i mean i had a view master and like
sometimes for presents like for a
stocking stuffer or something somebody
would give me like the little reels
because i'm pretty sure i had one like
from like a disneyland one and i had
like some other ones but somebody i
don't know who
gave me one that was a kiss view master
reel
so it had like 3d pictures of all of
them like in action poses with like
their signatures and like sparkly kind
of
isn't that [ __ ] funny i just remember
i had forgotten all about that and i
just remembered it when you said
who the how the [ __ ] did i get that why
would i have had that just some cheesy
[ __ ] because like i said i was a little
i was a little kid so i didn't know buy
it did they have those in germany sandra
it's a view masters little thing you put
on your head yeah it's red it looked
like vr goggles a little bit it was
around paper discs with [ __ ] pictures
pitch yourself but they were 3d pictures
3d you go like that and see them yeah
i used to love that [ __ ] man because i
was like whoa man you could actually get
your photographs done in view master if
you probably could well because i think
all they have to do is you just have to
like offset like one eye from the other
eye because it fools your brain into
like thinking
yeah it's like pretty easy to do i think
you could do that i know you could get
it in slides
yeah but i was thinking them or there
might have been a camera that could do
it because i think there has to be two
images
yeah you have to have two images that
are slightly offset from one another
from what i remember
um
yeah so yeah esther said i had a view
master yeah
uh and pat said i had one too but i
don't remember a kiss one i don't i had
totally forgotten and it was like a
whole because how many pictures were on
that reel i'm trying to think it was
like a dozen at least no i don't think
it was that many no i think it was
because oh well maybe
i thought it was like 12 like maybe 10.
i don't know 10 or so you forgot about
them yeah
well i had totally forgotten about the
kiss one until you were talking about
kiss and then it just like the picture
of it like flashed in my mind i can't
remember
maybe they were like stage photos and
stuff like that but i do remember like
the posed
ones because it was like a black
background but like each member was like
you know he'd have like the guitar and
he'd be like whoa it's coming at you and
then they'd be like the
the [ __ ] signature next to it and it
was just kind of like i thought it was
neat but it was just like i was
i wasn't ever like into kiss so i was
just kind of like okay
whoever these dudes like i knew who they
were but it's like i don't listen to
them or anything so that's why i'm kind
of like trying to remember
why i would have had that
i had a bunch of different ones but i
don't know why i had to kiss one
particularly it's just kind of like when
i was thinking the other day about
god we were talking the other day about
[ __ ] back in the back in the old days
when they had like planetariums they
sell planetariums but um
when they had like the laser light shows
and you would go and it'd be like you
know one band or whatever one type of
music and then they would do like all
the laser lights and [ __ ] and
i grew up in daytona beach it was like
not much to do except like country
western bars
so every now and then they would do like
you know lazarium type of shows and it'd
be like usually like pink floyd or led
zeppelin or something like that and um
so we would go to them if we were really
bored they had a duran duran one
actually which was like super fun um we
went to
a beatles one we went to that a couple
times but that was like kind of cool
because they not only had the lasers but
they also had people
like in sort of glow-in-the-dark like
costumes like because i remember the
beatles one and this was a long time ago
but i remember the beatles one they had
somebody like dressed like kind of like
an octopus they were doing like
octopus's garden and then like they had
somebody like an octopus but it looked
glowed so it was like you know what i
mean so and it was dark in there so it
was like kind of cool because it was
like people in costumes like walking
around at the bottom of the planetarium
too like in costumes so it wasn't just
the lasers it was like other [ __ ] too i
remember one time in particular we were
super super bored and we ended up going
to one we were like let's go see like
what the laser light show is at the
planetarium because that's how bored we
were and it turned out to be [ __ ]
journey and i was like i was like oh man
really they're like yeah but there's
nothing else to do and i'm just like
okay fine and i had a really really bad
cold and you know if you're you know
when you go to the planetarium and like
this the seats kind of go back right so
you can like look at the ceiling and
it's like the whole time and i'm like
sitting there like watching the lasers
and like listening to [ __ ] journey
and i'm sitting there going
because i couldn't breathe because my
nose was like i didn't want to blow my
nose because everyone would like look at
me and it was just like it was a
miserable [ __ ] experience and it's
like for some reason every time i think
about journey i always think about that
[ __ ] night of me not being able to
breathe because my [ __ ] nose was all
blocked up oh my god that was like so
[ __ ] long ago
i don't it's weird like
how [ __ ] like that like sticks with you
you know
[Laughter]
victor says i love journey
um
you know what to be honest with you i
like separate ways
uh i've you know i was gonna say it was
a guilty pleasure song but i'm not
guilty about it that's a good song
other than that
you know
i could i could take it or leave it
but
i kind of feel like because like i said
i grew up in daytona it's kind of like
if you didn't have
for a long time we didn't really have
any good radio stations so you either
had a country station
or you had like the classic rock station
so a lot of times most of the places
where i worked you know they'd have the
radio playing
at work just you know for whatever
reason
and since most people you know were like
since country music was a little more
divisive i guess so they would always
have the classic rock station on so and
my dad was really into all that classic
rock stuff like he really liked like the
eagles and stuff so and leonard skinner
and whatnot so
by the time like i was in my 20s or
something like that i was so [ __ ]
sick of all that kind of music that i
could just scream
you know what i mean so because
everywhere i worked i was just kind of
like really okay we're gonna listen to
this [ __ ] that all just fell into the
classic rock that's what i'm saying it
was like you know it's i mean daytona i
don't know if it's still there now but
we had a station called the hog
and it was all
classic rock they mostly played like
southern rock like i said it was like
leonard skynyrd or two you know but they
play like the eagles and [ __ ] like that
um you know and sometimes the doors but
not usually they didn't play like really
cool [ __ ]
i kind of feel like in later years they
might have gone a little bit more like
and they might have updated some [ __ ]
like they started playing like some 80s
van halen and then they started playing
like some 90s grungy type like sound
garden and stuff
but
i don't know by that time i was just
kind of like
sick of it and like over it so
i don't know that's that's maybe why i i
don't have like
it it's inoffensive to me you know what
i mean it's just generic that's what i
mean it's like a lot of times i just
kind of can i i can tune it out because
i've heard those songs so many times
because they never played anything
like weird or like off the wall or
anything like that it was always like
the same
you know 20 songs over and over
that they kept saying that people were
requesting i'm like who are these people
that are that are requesting the same
song that's been played every same
people that are every every three hours
for
40 years this yes
[ __ ] um that margaritaville song
oh my god i have a [ __ ] story about
that too because they're [ __ ] driving
you nuts i moved to
uh i lived in tampa for a little while
in the early
2000s and i worked at a print shop
and the dude that owned the print shop
was he was a nice dude
but
he was the world's biggest jimmy buffett
fan right so it's like every single day
you would come in and he had i'm sure he
had like all of jimmy buffett's entire
catalog which i don't know that much
about jimmy buffets i don't know how big
that catalog is
but he liked this one particular cd
so much
that
he would play it like just over and over
and over and over again
so it's like in a work day as well like
eight or nine hours long right so you'd
be there and i'd be in the back in my
office like doing my you know graphic
design and laying out stuff for a print
for the print uh the press and
everything and it's just like i'm like
oh my god here we go again this [ __ ]
jimmy here's math sucks again that jimmy
buffett song i don't know why that's the
only thing that sucks math sucks yeah he
wrote a [ __ ] song called maths he
he
did
and i was like
and i'm always gonna i don't know like
it's all that kind of like oh i'm dumb
and i'm proud of it kind of attitude i'm
just like that's always kind of like
pissed me off so it's like that song
like really pissed me off
like more than it just being like a
stupid terrible song with stupid
terrible lyrics but i'm just like oh
okay
you're admitting government you're
stupid and like you're
being you're making some kind of stand
about it good for you all right i don't
know that's just like maybe really bad
he's not good at math
[Laughter]
and it's like it's funny i didn't work
there that long but it's like there was
this young kid that worked there too
like this boy that like helped him like
he was a boy he was like in his 20s and
he helps the guy like run the press and
that guy even though he was like much
younger was also super new jimmy buffett
and when i worked there both of them
went to like jimmy buffett played in
tampa and they were super stoked and
they like went and saw him and then
after that
it's like they played it it was like
even worse because then they were just
like
not only playing that same cd over and
over but then they're like reminiscing
about the show remember when he did this
and i was like oh my god please kill me
but like i said i got a i got another
job like not too long after that so
they were nice but you know come on
don't inflate jimmy buffett on people
that
i would rather just have like some
generic radio station on that's like
some [ __ ] that they played down the keys
though
down the tourists down in tourist center
areas yeah okay look i found
i found oh finally he's alessandra he's
been like looking at that this whole
time
that's what you're imagining that she
looks like that's sandra yeah well no
one else can see it okay
[Laughter]
this is sandra all right the one
one is shaving my back the one that's
shaving your back i want to shave my
back okay
she's from germany so i know that that's
that that's
that's her
that's her that look and everything
ah that's her
can a mod block a mod i don't know i
don't know mango can they wait who are
you trying to block i don't know i just
look i'm kind of behind
we can always make that mod and not a
bod
uh
victor says classic rock these days
plays some 41 weezer and blink 182 and
it makes me sad yeah i did kind of uh
see that it was going more in that
direction
um
you know i still feel like an old person
every time i'm in a grocery store and
hear like a music version of like a cure
song or something so but it happens to
everybody
your your music will eventually become
classic rock and it'll get played in
commercials and [ __ ] like that
you remember the other day we were
talking about
this was like years ago but remember
that uh commercial for
carnival cruise lines
that used that iggy pop song
lust for life
were we talking about that the other day
i think we mentioned it on here actually
see she said almost almost
that's right i think that's i figured
that's what i was doing she's playing
into your fantasy stuff yeah
all i see are boobs on the screen says
stila well that's all tom really cares
about that's not true that's that girl
he just cares about boobs oh you have a
face okay that's not true but it's not
true i'm just [ __ ] with you son we're
just [ __ ] with you tom
like i said he's a lot of [ __ ] with me
but i can't [ __ ] with him back he gets
all like so funny because we were at the
club last night and jenny's [ __ ]
monday night monday night jenny had her
[ __ ] rack was presented in the
[ __ ] our friend the bartender yeah
tiff tiff's [ __ ] was just [ __ ] all
out i'm in the middle on the side of the
bar like that like i went over here one
over here and i'm sitting here and i'm
[ __ ] talking about their boobs and
[ __ ] they're just like going like this
and i said see i got the seat of honor
here man between the two
best biggest racks in this [ __ ] club
and our friend alicia was over there she
was like
and it says oh no you too you too okay
yeah
yeah yeah yeah it's like hey what about
me yeah yeah
yeah
you got it including your daughter was
right next to her though i gotta include
all the ladies yeah i had to include
them all you gotta include all the
ladies
she's she's stacked too but she's you
know but no it's you know it's a
different magnitude you know what i'm
talking about you have to well yeah
different magnitude me and tiff are kind
of like yeah those are the big girls
there
love you too
she seriously she's like the sweetest
chick ever yeah but um
yeah picture of her we show her on the
show one of these days i probably i
think i have a picture of her somewhere
i'm sure i do we've said you know we've
been going there so long but um yeah i
was gonna say yeah if you're gonna like
compliment you can't just like
compliment one lady yeah this is
everyone insulted that every then
everybody's just kind of like oh so i'm
just like the [ __ ] ugly steps this is
the start over here this is the thing
she's sucking what 18 yeah and i'm being
a sexist pig with middle-aged women next
to me which you can get away with that
if they're if you're friends with them
and i'm gonna throw her in the middle i
didn't realize that she would get
jealous
thank you dom the bomb i didn't realize
tom strange world iron maiden first
album thoughts
uh
strange world i don't remember that one
what's tom drinking today
that is oh it's free orange juice and
fruit punch vodka which is a new one we
haven't got that we just saw in the
liquor store and i'm like yeah that
sounds kind of good he got that with
orange juice i have cherry vodka and
it's bright
yeah it's that's the thing it's like a
lot of ways we're old people and it's
like you know and we've known these
people for like years and years so like
you can [ __ ] with them and you know
they're not going to take it seriously
sandra said that looks almost like me
except for the booze
yeah then she goes and the hair
oh and the nose and then the hand the
face and the face
never mind it doesn't look like anything
in the face yeah yeah yeah everybody
doesn't like yeah
damn santa you got some really nice eyes
oh my god yeah um
esther said do i ever get jealous of
tom um
no
no would you be jealous to me for that's
yeah i don't i don't really know why i
would be yeah
it's not
that's what i mean i don't know it's
like that's like that's a
that's an interesting question
no
jealous in what sense i don't know
you're not prettier than me i think
she's trying to say that
i have bigger boobs than you i'm
prettier than you
i'm nicer than you
well no i mean i'm less of an [ __ ]
than you yeah but that's part of that
charm is being [ __ ] if i wasn't
absolutely that's true if i wasn't an
[ __ ] [ __ ] i'd just be ignored
that's true yeah
well like that's it for me guys you no
well don't do that because it's like
it's a fine line it's a fine line you
gotta know what you're doing you can't
be just like an [ __ ] ham and [ __ ]
because then you're just an [ __ ] and
you're just [ __ ] yeah you you are an
[ __ ] but like with a sense of humor
and like you're not taking it seriously
no you know what i mean that's all game
and everybody knows well everybody
that's known you for any length of time
knows that when you when you go like
that you're just being funny it's part
of my sense of humor right and so
everybody knows that and so the thing is
is that you know oh that's time
i'm extremely arrogant all right but i
could back it up with certain things
that i'm very arrogant but i'm also
self-effacing
in in a certain way yeah uh like i said
it's a good combo because i know that
i'm being that way
you know what i mean when i do that i'm
doing that kind of on purpose it's
almost kind of like a ploy
it's almost like it's because
um
for from my whole life i was in starting
off in a military academy
you're constantly trying to keep morale
very high
because the power of the mind and
positive thinking
has a lot to do
with endurance and to endure hardship
so you're constantly talking about what
a [ __ ] badass you are i'm a [ __ ]
badass you know just listen but mostly
what that is is it's psyching yourself
up
but you are a badass when you're psyched
up
if you're demoralized
you'll falter you'll weaken and you'll
falter you have to constantly be looking
at the very positive side of everything
or you have to see danger and then you
kind of have to kind of get off on the
danger that's another thing too
like
if something's something if you see
something
and something kind of threatens you or
there's a looming threat
instead of shirking away from it it's
actually
more healthy for me to kind of fixate on
it
that a threat is coming
and that was just but that but that's
you know and i got cops in here too that
i grew up with they'll probably tell you
that they're probably the same way
because
paramilitary units are like that
they're constantly focusing you on
things that are bad that it's coming you
have to get ready
and you actually feel a lot better
because you're not
cowering in fear or shrinking away or
running it it's quite the opposite
and
so you're
trying to psych yourself up into like a
near kamikaze type mentality
and it just becomes a normal part of
your personality over time when it's
gone you miss it
yeah you know jenny lives with me she
knows exactly what i'm talking about
yeah i know what you're talking about
yeah no esther said she she meant uh
looking at other women
i used to care but i don't anymore well
part of this is the show
yeah yeah
you know what i mean
like i said i used to care but i don't
know what to do
i'm just kind of like whatever yeah
you never know what's going to happen
jenny might feel the same way she's just
not saying that saying the same thing
what does that mean well you never mind
are we going to have some kind of
revelation on it i don't know i actually
don't know what we should already know
if they're long-term listeners but don't
matter
[Laughter]
nobody gets this well we're too old to
give a shout-out to give a [ __ ] i kind
of feel like i'm too old to give a [ __ ]
yeah which is kind of nice actually yeah
that's one of the best things that's
actually one of the only good things
about getting old is like you don't give
crap about stuff anymore which is kind
of nice you know like over man when we
went out with the [ __ ] kids last
night they started [ __ ] this thing
they [ __ ] left she left at a huff you
know what i mean
because he was [ __ ]
well we're we're assuming that we don't
know she just gets jealous over
everything
well she's very young yeah
i mean it's a you know hormones
well that's that's what happens when
you're young when you're really young
it's like you know i was i was that age
once day oh that was a long time ago i
hardly remember but um
but you know a lot of uh girls
especially that age are like very
insecure
so you know any any kind of like
little thing that seems like like he's
looking at somebody on the dance floor
and oh the guy's gotta put it
you know gotta put a stop to that you
know what i mean
yeah it's had some drama drama yeah and
i was just kind of like oh my god and i
don't think i don't know that that
happened but i suspect that's what
happened it might have been yeah but
yeah i don't i don't want to get too
much into it because she comes here
sometimes but
i think it was uh just him being himself
and that's just what people do and some
some people are not ready for that
but they get used to it
yeah you know it's not a big deal
no it's not no
i mean like i said let me take those
dishes do you want a new uh drink yeah
that's only yeah there's that one
there's already sprite in that
no it's uh it's empty because i because
i i refilled i mean
that was just the ice thing
that's what that's water i'm gonna keep
that
but um yeah well you know
and i gotta say like you're you're a
woman you gotta put up with a lot
you gotta accommodate so you know what i
mean you don't always like it but what
are you gonna do
um yeah taylor says i'm seriously
thinking of subbing to this voltaire
dude he has a vid on how to make acorn
squash two-way's got style yeah he's
actually like a pretty cool dude like i
said if you want to listen to his music
like his he has like a great singing
voice and his songs are like [ __ ]
super hilarious
i feel like he did music for
man some of those like cartoons that
were on cartoon network back like what
was it um
god damn it
mandy and the [ __ ] grim and what the
[ __ ] was the name of that cartoon god
damn it this looks such a long time ago
i feel like he did like some music for
that for some shows on the cartoon
network but yeah like his songs are like
super funny um and he seems like a nice
dude and like i said he's kind of like a
goth homemaker type dude so like yeah
he's always kind of like decorating and
cooking and stuff but all like goth
style
uh which is pretty awesome so yeah i i
didn't know actually that he had that
plenty of ice in there okay thank you i
didn't know that he had that until i saw
him on jade's show like i knew you know
i have some of his albums and stuff but
i didn't know that he had like a whole
youtube channel him like decorating [ __ ]
and i'm just like oh my god i need to
get in on that but uh
and he like does cooking and whatnot too
so i thought that was like pretty funny
was it it's so fizzy that's cause you
didn't draw you didn't drop it down the
side
well you know i don't have time for that
i'm doing just like just like on beer
and board games where it's like he's he
he just said it's like this much head
he's like look i bought it like an
[ __ ]
[Laughter]
you're pouring it like an [ __ ]
why is it funnier when you when you
don't say an [ __ ] it's always funnier
when you say like a [ __ ] i don't know
why because i don't know it's just
funnier to me
[Laughter]
grim adventures of billy and mandy thank
you i can remember the name of that
[ __ ] show to save my life
uh oh
he's getting mad
oh it's the sexual tyrannosaur exactly
what is that what does that mean what
does that portend
nothing nothing just means i'm on phase
two he's on phase two
i danced to that didn't i more western i
can't help but dance to bear steers and
queers every time they play it
even though it's like so cheesy esther
says uh you and tom complement each
other yeah cause we're like
we're really really different but
it's almost kind of i guess that's kind
of why we started hanging out because
it's like you
you have like i don't know we're in some
ways i don't know for total opposites
but no no not really no not really
but it's kind of like
just we our attributes are almost
opposite yeah that's not that's not
really the personalities aren't that
different yeah that's true
they're not yeah because you're like a
lot more outgoing than me you're a lot
more you're outgoing too you still
realize it
i'm outgoing when i'm drunk yeah not not
when i'm sober
[Laughter]
well i chose she's a lot more aggressive
than she thinks she is she thinks no i
know i am yeah she's
some people you know it's not just her
me too you tend to see yourself
you tend to see yourself as you thought
of yourself when you were a lot younger
like
13 14 15 16 i think it's because a lot
of that is when your identity
your self-awareness first started to
form you know
so you kind of see it from that
perspective sometimes a lot of times you
know what i mean like when i dream
in my dreams i'm in my 20s still
isn't that interesting isn't that weird
yeah i never dream anything no um when
i'm dreaming i'm almost always in my 20s
i'm usually not even me when i dream
oh no
and i'm almost always in the army
in a uniform and i'm talking to my
friends back then it's at least the
dreams that i remember
you know
and i'm always about 25
so i think jenny imagines herself a lot
of times as she was
not as she is now even though i can't
even remember what i was like really
it might i sort of do but
it was such a long time ago that i don't
really but that's interesting what you
said about dreams though because i was
just like i said i was watching uh i was
watching that girl like earlier today
and she was talking but she was doing
like a vlog and she was talking about a
dream that she had
and she dreamed she was talking about
like school dreams she's like even
though i haven't been in school for like
a really long time like oh my god you
know i didn't go to this class or
whatever and i know that's like a pretty
common dream to have i hardly ever have
dreams like that and i i do i do high
school too i'm dreaming that i'm in high
school i don't think i've i don't i
don't think i've dreamed about being in
high school for i don't even remember
the last time whenever i have a dream
that i'm in high school i'm looking at
my damn schedule trying to figure out
what class i have next and my [ __ ]
schedule's just all over the [ __ ]
place see a lot of people have dreams
like that yeah
i don't remember i don't remember and
the bell's ringing and people are going
to classic which was my what what's the
next class
um
but now jenny sees herself as a teenager
i think a lot of times and she sees
herself
as the poor trailer park teenager not
really all that popular in the lame
clothes so that's not who she is she
hasn't been that for a long time
but her point of view is from that
which is a good thing i don't know
because
yeah kind of sees the underdog but
jenny's not an underdog she's a
successful writer and she's very popular
and uh in the scenes in the circles that
we travel and she's [ __ ] high status
so
she
she remembers where she comes from but
she forgets who she is
but see i'm glad in a way that way i'm
kind of glad of that though because it's
like i don't i don't want to be one of
those people that's just kind of like
has a big [ __ ] head and i don't do it
on purpose yeah it's just that one i
know how quickly like fortunes can
change yeah um you know because i've
seen that happen
and
i just don't want to like i don't
that that's just part of my personality
i never wanted to be like up myself like
oh i'm so much better
it's gonna be difficult i'm just not
like that it's gonna be difficult for
fortunes to change permanently because
of what level of development you're in
you're not
you're a successful person you have too
many faculties and too many facilities
at hand
you know what i mean
to to win
in terms of knowledge and skills
so you won't be moving backwards unless
you have a stroke
you know
which that could happen like that's what
i'm saying like i said yes way down the
line like a [ __ ] piano can fall in my
head i don't know right but it's just
you know i mean it's probably not going
to but
never say never no i'm just saying that
i don't know i think i have more of like
a realistic
and like i said i'm just not the type of
person that is gonna be like up myself
because i think i was i don't know if
this is like genetically part of my
personality or just the way i was raised
or whatever it was but
i was kind of raised in a sense that
look no one like no one is better than
you if somebody else learned to do
something you can learn to do it too
um you know so don't like think oh this
person's like oh they're successful and
you can't do that like don't think about
that but in a way that kind of gave me a
thing where it's like well everybody has
something to offer
you know what i mean so
i don't know so but i always kind of
like i do have like a lot of
self-deprecating
thing i'm very self-critical which i
think a lot of creative people are but
if i wasn't like that i don't think i
would get as much done as i do because
i'm constantly having to like is this
good enough like and yeah and i'm never
happy with anything i put out ever i
mean look it's like you know i just got
yesterday i got one of my um
little game crafter games that i made
because remember i said i was going to
enter that small box challenge
uh so i did like a like a scaled-down
version of one of my bigger games
because it had to be like under a
certain size it had to be under a
certain price and it had to have you
know a certain number of components so i
made another one
and i just got it
and
the reason they take me so long to do i
just finished the halloween game by the
way and i ordered the proof
but the reason they take me so long to
do is because
no matter how much i work on it and no
matter how much other people tell me
it's like oh my god that's beautiful
blah blah blah and i'm just like yeah
but
i could have done this or i could have
done that it's i was i never ever
satisfied with anything i ever do um no
mr roboto i don't have a rambo wig but
if you send me one i'll wear it
oh my god that's one you don't have what
was another one also said that i
transformed i don't know what you're
talking about there's no context
if you guys uh make comments in the
comments section please give context
because we're not really following the
discussion that's in there and if you
throw out random [ __ ] we don't know what
you're talking about well sometimes like
i try to keep track but sometimes i
glance away for a couple seconds and
it's like i can't really esther says
you're a perfectionist yeah i am yeah
and in a in a way when i was younger
that actually uh worked against me
because it like stifled me um from doing
things because like i would like for
example i would write a short story or
something and then i would read it and
be like oh my god that sucks and then i
would just like throw it away where
probably it was workable and i could
have like edited it and like it probably
would have been good but if it didn't
come out perfect the first time this is
when i was younger um then i would just
throw it away and start over pat said he
had one of those oh i'm late for school
dreams just recently yeah i'd have those
too
it's not funny yeah
i don't think i've had a dream like that
since maybe i was in my 30s which was a
long time ago no i'm i'm pretty much in
my
i'm either in high school in my teens or
i'm in my 20s in the army usually
of the dreams that i remember
sometimes i'm not me although sometimes
i have had dreams where i was riding on
a motorcycle never had the dream that i
was riding on my uh on my bike and it
was at the intersection saw the ufo go
over me yeah i remember that remember
you tell me i woke up to jenny man i saw
a ufo of my dreams it was [ __ ] looked
real as [ __ ]
yeah you were very descriptive about
what it looked like i was sitting there
just [ __ ] just astounded by this
thing i remember pretty much every
detail of it it was [ __ ] cheesy as
[ __ ] but i was just convinced i was
seeing a ufo for real
and then it was a dream though but it
just felt like i was there
standing in that intersection on that
buell with my foot down with fuel
stopped and all the traffic
traffic just came to a standstill we
watched this huge [ __ ]
ufo that kind of looked like a
merry-go-round out of the damn it's a
small world ride on disneyland it looked
like it was made out of damn stucco
green
wouldn't that be awesome if like aliens
actually came here in a ufo that looked
like it's a small world look like
somebody it's a small world it was i
want to hang out with those
and it was so [ __ ] bizarre like oh i
see what you did there so [ __ ]
bizarre that i was going oh yeah that
shit's alien no human would have
decorated some [ __ ] like that
it was like avocado greens stucco
except walt disney it had an upper and a
lower deck it was [ __ ] round and it
looked like a merry-go-round with poles
but instead of horses that had little
swirling gold [ __ ] spheres and
[ __ ] like that and on the inside of
it
you know like behind the poles it had
mirrors that went around it and lights
shining i go man that's just tacky look
at that [ __ ] look how [ __ ] tacky that
thing is and it was scary though man the
aliens there's a tacky ass [ __ ] and i
was trying to grasp
what's all those [ __ ] spinning poles
for how does that work it didn't make
any stripper poles yeah like stripper
poles on him how how does that [ __ ]
work
that's for this alien i couldn't take my
eyes off of it it was huge it was like
because sometimes when they get in the
atmosphere they have all the alien
strippers and they're just out there on
the outside like to lure people in
that's like what they're doing it was uh
it was low
the bottom of it was maybe about
six stories above the ground
and it was about the size of a
about the size of a
giant circus tent that's about how big
it was
like a giant how did we just watch
killer clowns from outer space is that
what you do no but it just look at a
circle you know about the size of a
circus but yeah about like that's what i
was thinking that's aliens like a couple
of um you could probably fit like four
um
four tennis courts in it
that's how big it was all right
and uh it just didn't look like anything
a human would make like a human would
have much better sense to make something
look like that oh i don't know about
that
and it had poles around it and it was
all spinning like it's a small world
after a little thing sucking that's what
it was like you know what i mean
and on the poles it had like
spheres it with little balls and [ __ ] it
looked like it looked you know how oh
you know like it's a small one is it
[ __ ] weird [ __ ] mechanical fake
looking mechanical steampunk looking
[ __ ] how [ __ ] awesome would that be
yeah and i was looking at it
what the [ __ ] does that do and i was
thinking it's like is that something to
do with any gravity or what the hell you
know i just didn't couldn't understand
maybe they just put it on there for the
hell of it just for looks i guess they
just thought it was well my subconscious
came up with maybe maybe these aliens
have been monitoring us but they're only
they unbeknownst to them they've only
been monitoring disneyland so they think
that everyone on earth is like
disneyland so that's like their only
context for human life or you know what
i mean yeah so they're like well we'll
build something which won't be
threatening to them yeah
so it's just kind of like anything so
they have like a spaceship that looks
like [ __ ] uh space mountain yeah
the only thing that was missing was the
little [ __ ] puppets
had the little puppets oh my god or like
a teddy bear on it or something i better
write that story now how funny would
that be yeah
it wouldn't be a horror story well i
could make it a horror story but that
would be like super super funny oh my
god what a great idea pastor tom your
[ __ ] dreams are detailed no it was
man dude it was like real
if they're not always that detailed
it's just that i always wanted to see a
ufo i saw poultry guys but he still
wants to see it i want to see he leaves
the curtains on the sliding glass door
open every night in the room yeah
because you can look out like to the sky
and even though i'm kind of like can you
close the curtains because it's like as
soon as the sun comes up it wakes me up
yeah but he's like no i have to leave it
open in case he focuses
because he wants to see the us
headphones on looking out that window
and i'm also
ready for somebody to step out there and
i [ __ ] you know step in and step out
and [ __ ] look at me like that too
i'll bless that [ __ ] if he does it but
i'm looking through there
yeah i've seen enough horror movies that
i'm just kind of yeah it's all right i'm
not worried about because well i'm not
actually worried about it either because
it's like i almost did see ufo that one
remember when i got out of bed [ __ ]
right outside went outside naked looking
at that [ __ ] thing that turned out it
was a helicopter
do you remember that did we talk about
that
this wasn't that long ago no what was it
like a month ago a couple months back
maybe a month or two ago yeah it's
probably about three o'clock in the
morning it was like yeah it was early in
the morning he like you woke me up right
yeah
yeah i knew something like it
and there was something outside and he
was just like flying look look look and
see you ran outside i'm pretty were you
naked yeah i'm pretty sure he's gonna
get a [ __ ] in the morning i mean it's
like you know it's not work
we're not on a major road or anything
there's like there's like a backyard
wall you know and there's like yeah
you know and then there's like a path
and there's trees what it was there's
the road i was sitting there just
confounded by it looked like two discs
with [ __ ] patterns going it was a
police helicopter well i could i told
you i was like dude i'm pretty sure it's
a helicopter well the whole outside lit
up because he had hit me with the
spotlight he didn't hit me but he hit
the house with the spotlight because
then i started [ __ ] he's like he's
looking for you thomas
yeah and i went out there and looked
and it had an led display on the
helicopter and it was it
was
i had forgotten yeah
he runs his little booty is like he's
outside the back
yeah
he goes down at this place man
i keep it's exciting in this house
i do all kinds of weird [ __ ] sometimes
i had totally forgotten about that that
you ran in the backyard naked going like
look it's a look jenny look it's a ufo
yeah yeah yeah yeah and then i was of
course one i'm always like cranky if you
wake me up
seriously i'm very cranky she's pissed
because i never get enough sleep i feel
like so it's like you wake me up the
mill and i'm like this better be is this
[ __ ] house on fire no then shut the
[ __ ] up
so it's kind of like so i ran out there
and i'm like dude that's that's a plane
or like a helicopter or something coming
out yeah it was a helicopter with a
searchlight and once i got outside i
heard the rotors
i think was the oh-58
and
but it had
it had a really cool led display
around the tail rotor and something
around the nose it looked like red discs
and there were things moving and it had
writing that was scrolling by
weird i didn't know that they were doing
that with that well because at first i
thought it was a blimp yeah i think i
thought it was a blimp yeah it was but
it was a it was a it was a police
helicopter with a bunch of led lights on
it and it said had something written on
it and it was displaying some kind of
message and it was shooting a laser beam
no it was a [ __ ] searchlight it was
yeah they were sucking cows up yeah
sucking cows up now i was shooting a
searchlight
out by that back road so there was
somebody down there they were [ __ ]
with somebody they were looking for
somebody incidentally that reminded me
have you guys seen there is a lamp for
sale out there uh a print shop i used to
work at um they had one and it was
it was magical um
it's a lamp and the top of it is a ufo
like your classic 50s
you know flying saucer
and then it's like lucite or something
and it's like yellow and it's like this
cone yeah and that's the part that
lights up and then in the middle there's
like a little cowl suspended as though
like he's sucking the cow up it's a it's
a wonderful wonderful lamp and we used
to have it like me and the other like
guy that owned the place and he was like
also a graphic designer and we used to
have that lamp in the middle of the desk
and every time i looked at it it just
like made me smile yeah i'm sure pretty
sure they still tell it you said lucite
that's the way that ufo i dreamt about
look like it looked like
stucco
you know
stucco and lucite is what it looked like
like spun lucite with the [ __ ] it was
green with like gold highlights
it looked tacky as [ __ ]
i would love that how awesome would it
be if like the aliens came in something
that looked like a 70s [ __ ] van yeah but
like and but like a ufo version of that
like you go inside like you get sucked
up it's got a [ __ ] airbrushing of an
aztec on the side like that right and
you get like getting ready to plunge a
dagger in her heart you know and you can
like do that [ __ ] and you get like
pulled up you get pulled up into the ufo
and like all the walls are covered with
shag carpeting
oh my god
and there's like an eight-track player
yeah come on aliens up your game
i would [ __ ] i would be like yeah man
all right take me with you um yeah tila
said is the public ready to accept alien
life though i mean humans are crazy most
would go insane if the if alien life
landed i don't know i kind of feel like
it would be one of those things where
it's already been accepted yeah they
thought mars yeah i feel like it might
be kind of like upsetting at first but i
think people would get you pretty
quickly honestly if the aliens seem cool
i'd be like hey all right take me away
yeah um people think when people worry
about first contact they had first
contact in the 1800s
people forget about this because
scientists no lowell and all those guys
they were convinced that there was life
on mars and they could see aqueducts and
that there were beings there
and you know people writing books about
mar martian being attacked by martians
like war of the worlds people already
believed that there were
intelligent beings on mars and it didn't
really change them that much they didn't
really i mean i kind of feel like
everyone's like down with the sci-fi now
so it's just kind of like oh well that's
well we were expecting that it's fine
we're going to find something soon
avi loeb he uh who is like he's like a
harvard
uh big wig and
he's into all that [ __ ] he's getting the
financing together to put this uh
this array of uh
telescopes together put them in orbit
uh at least 20 or 30 of them up to 100
of them and they're just going to do a
survey they're just going to look for
moving objects
and analyze them and it's going to be a
bunch of data and it's not going to save
any of the data
because it wouldn't be able to
because it would be so vast it's just
going to look for anything that does not
match
you know what i mean anything out of the
ordinary and then it will lock in on it
and they're looking for like
discarded debris
because uh there's a good chance
that you're gonna find
junk space junk floating around
or maybe a ship
and that might take a long time
but uh they haven't really done a survey
like this before
you know they're looking for they're
looking directly at stars
they're looking for more stuff closer
inside the solar system they're looking
for junk going by yeah because that's
what happens in the oceans
you know what i mean you can be out on
the ocean and see a coke bottle going by
well [ __ ] man there's there's whole like
whirlpools of garbage garbage out there
yeah
so let's
something went by about about a year or
so ago what was that thing called a
muammar
and
oh yeah i remember right now it came and
then i got people it accelerated on its
way out
and it seemed to be
not massive
about the size of a tennis court
and thin
and
it accelerated when it went out
and it wasn't hydrogen burning off of it
it was old whatever it was it's
something that's been traveling and it
came into the solar system at a high
rate of speed
different from the normal flow of
traffic
of the stars as they swirl through
so it was something that had speed
applied to it at some time in its
history
and it summarized that it was just like
a flat
maybe just a flat piece of junk
like a an array and a solar array maybe
off of like a solar sail but it wouldn't
have been from earth
and it wouldn't it was light whatever it
was but it didn't it hasn't been burned
up by solar radiation so it wasn't some
kind of like frozen gas
it was something solid
um
and as it left
the
solar system as it passed the sun it
accelerated
some people were saying well the heat
hitting it maybe caused gas to escape
from it which gave it like rocket power
and then they came back said no because
they'd gone through many solar systems
in its life on the trajectory
it would have been burned up by now or
you know evaporated by now if it was
some kind of frozen gas
it was something that was very thin and
didn't have much weight to it enough
that solar radiation could accelerate it
they did the math and everything and the
only thing close to that would have been
a light sheet
of like aluminum like on a solar sail or
like a a piece of debris about the size
of a
tennis court
it was strange whatever it was they just
gonna they want to look for more of them
it might have been something
natural some kind of natural phenomenon
but avi loeb
believes it was the leftovers of some
kind of a solar sail from another
civilization there's totally plausible
totally plausible it's like look we
found a spark plug from an alien space
right well a solar sail requires very
little technology
you know you can put a solar sail on
anything
and it'll get some speed
um and if it ever breaks loose it could
be floating out there in the galaxy for
[ __ ] trillions of years it would
survive galaxies if grouse is big and
something like that would just last
forever
because there's nothing really to
destroy you know you're talking about
something maybe like as thin as a piece
of plastic
you know a piece of tin foil
yeah just lasts forever
you know that's what i mean usually like
so put [ __ ] out there it's like it
doesn't go anywhere go anywhere
it was an anomaly and there if if you
don't see more of it then the chances
are it was something that was
manufactured by somebody at some time in
the past
and that's the people always talking
about you know finding alien species
living creatures coming out take us to
your leader all that shit's very
unlikely
far more likely that if you meet any
living extraterrestrial it's going to be
a living machine
that has a
very vast intelligence kind of like
something out of 2001
or
you're going to find
more likely that you would ever find
anything
live would be some kind something having
to do with archaeology something that
died a long time ago or a piece of junk
that was made a long long time ago
because that could be around forever
you know what i mean
in other words the foot once the
footprint is made it's going to be there
for a long long time
so chances are the first thing you're
going to find is something
like what they call it
extraterrestrial or alien archaeology
i would check like on the dark side of
the moon the very center see if there's
something there maybe somebody put a
monument there or something exactly on
the dumb north or south pole of the moon
or something in the place where it would
be
you'd have to want to go there and find
it you know
like maybe an obelisk on the very
highest point of a mountain somewhere on
some planet maybe somebody put something
up there
you you want to look in a weird place
something in orbit directly above a pole
like perfectly above a pole
maybe it's something that could be there
for trillions of years something like
that because there's enough time
in earth's life
that there could have been more than one
civilization here on this planet yeah
we've been here for like four billion
years something like that right yeah
well earth earth is bad i think it was
trillion was it trillion years four
trillion years or four billion years but
there's enough time for
there was there would have been enough
time for other civilizations non-human
civilizations to rise that's a long time
pre-dinosaur could have been shipped
pre-dinosaur and maybe they went to the
moon and they left things behind there
you know
no way of knowing tila was talking about
they're talking about alien life in
there uh alien life very different
looking at invasion of the body
snatchers that reminded me
when we were at momentum emory on monday
night
we were talking to our friend little
small little spoke and we were talking
about because he's real into horror
movies too although he's a bit younger
than us and he hasn't seen like a lot of
the classics
we were talking about
what would be
the scariest
not necessarily the scariest but the
most dangerous the most dangerous like
movie monster
and the alien uh no the thing or the
thing yeah
we said it would yeah we said it would
be the thing because
i was like that was something and i
think we talked about this before where
it's like you wouldn't be able to stop
it because you wouldn't it wouldn't look
the same
you know it's not like a xenomorph like
oh that's a xenomorph let's kill it
which might be difficult but at least
you recognize a xenomorph the thing from
the thing uh can look like whatever it
wants to look like so
and it to the same extent invasion of
the body snatchers would also be like
super scary because even though they
come here looking they just look like
regular ass plants but then they turn
into
people like they can take over people's
bodies although that was a little less
scary because at least you could tell
that the person had been taken over
because they were like acting super
weird in the thing you couldn't tell who
had been taken over and who couldn't
when it comes to biological life forms
aliens
you would think the most likely thing
that could survive would be the thing
that's kind of what i think if that if
something like that came here we would
be [ __ ] yeah but the thing is is that
what i'm what i'm getting at is that in
darwinian evolution
the most badass creatures rise to the
top and survive
something like the thing would be an
apex predator
it's i could surmise that something like
that must exist
well yeah that well that's what's so
scary about that movie is that that's
really not that far-fetched you would
think that that's what would that's what
a lot of life would eventually evolve
into
because
that's like the ultimate adaptability
because like i said it's not so much
being bigger or faster or stronger
anything like that it's being adaptable
and if you were so adaptable that she's
like i could appropriate any creature
you can anything right like any uh you
know climate that you found yourself in
they're like okay well what's all the
local flora and water will become that
and you'll just like proliferate yeah
that would be like that would take over
the earth like in no time at all you
would think that that would only happen
to have that would only have to happen
once in a galaxy and once that happened
that creature would achieve dominance
yeah i kind of feel like uh you could
uncreate that soon the whole galaxy
would just be that one organism
right but in a bunch of different forms
right
so that's why like i said that's why the
thing is like one of the best horror
movies ever yeah because if you think
about the implications of that that is
like scary [ __ ] and the crustal didn't
really defeat it
they just blew it up with dynamite that
wouldn't kill it no of course not uh but
see that's what's so great about that
movie they left it like ambiguity [ __ ]
really ambiguous you didn't know those
pieces would just be frozen up there
with him and crustle and [ __ ] keith
david they'd be up there frozen with the
thing they're just like looking at each
other and thinking i wonder if you're
the thing wouldn't hear the thing i
don't know it might be
and it's like if you are it's like even
like you said even if you blow it up
there's like little pieces of it right
and all you need is a little piece of it
i use like one cell i mean theoretically
xenomorphs you could defeat that
predator that's what i'm saying defeat
that yeah because that's a thing that's
a being that's easily identifiable right
it's a it's a high signature it's not a
low signature creature it doesn't have
any camouflage
you could fight that you couldn't fight
the thing nope that's what i'm saying
that's why i think that's the scariest
and the most dangerous movie
because there's just no way i can't
think of any conceivable way no that you
could defeat that if evolution ever
created something like that it would
survive and it would spread that's what
i mean we would be [ __ ] and something
like that might be out there
yeah because you know something like
that might be out there that would have
been the ultimate achievement for
biology to be able to do that
it just must be that that's very
unlikely that that happens
that must be near maybe that's
impossible
it could be that that's biologically
impossible
i you know what though i hate to say
this but i don't really see any barriers
to that from a biological standpoint i
mean maybe i'd have to think about it
more but it's basically a colony of
amoebas i don't see why how that
couldn't happen
what you're talking about is a colony of
amoebas
that jump on a living organism
consume it cell by cell
and then learn from its dna and takes
that shape once it once it's consumed
and even when it gets the brains of that
creature
it recreates that brain and the
knowledge that was inside of it yeah
because they're able to recreate
everything that was in like i said
invasion of the body snatchers had a
similar concept but you could tell that
that person wasn't them anymore because
they were like emotionless in the thing
it was them but in the thing it was them
you couldn't tell yeah um so in a way
that was kind of because if it took over
your whole entire brain it took all your
memories and everything like that it had
to access all of you and all your
knowledge right and then at any minute
it could become all the other creatures
that had ever contacted
you know they made big crab legs come
out and alien [ __ ] comes out it could
take whatever form it wanted man i want
some big crab legs yeah
do you know what i don't know why i just
thought of this well i guess because you
said crab i was just looking i was
getting some yogurt last night yeah and
i had forgotten that i bought a big
thing you got imitation for a fake crab
meat yeah and i was like when did i buy
that i don't remember buying that i
remember we got some celery
i'm like [ __ ] now i'm gonna make some
crab salad with that so i'm gonna make
some sandwiches i totally forgot that
was in the fridge we'll get some hoagie
rolls and some um now i gotta go to the
store again
but um
the uh everything else i got i got the
mayonnaise i got everything else i got
old bay everything
but um
yeah
yeah you couldn't beat the thing
no yeah and i was like get onto the
planet i've probably spent too much time
thinking about this because like i said
i'm a horror writer and i overthink
everything so
sometimes i kind of have these thought
experiments where it's just kind of like
well if something like that really did
exist like what could you do to fight
that because i'm trying to think of it
like from a story point of view like if
you were writing a story about this
um what could your protagonist do to
like fight that and
honestly i don't
there's not really a lot you could do
like i said if it escaped
you dumb
pretty much the entire earth would be
would be hosed you'd be hosed the only
other thing that was closer to that was
the the ayleid out of squirm
the little damn worms that we get in
your mouth slither you mean slither i
mean yeah not squirrel that's that's a
totally different word the little worm
things that would go in your mouth and
take over
that was close
um although like i said at least it was
identifiable that you'd been taken over
yeah you could fight it
the thing that was scary about the thing
is you couldn't identify who had been
taken over and who couldn't and i think
that was kind of like the the mitigating
factor there yeah you know invasion of
the body snatchers
you know yes they could replicate a
person but
most of the people were like hey um you
know my wife isn't my wife anymore like
she's on the promotion the pod [ __ ]
took time
that's right it took resources and at
least the pod the pod had to be like
kind of within proximity to you
the thing just had to be alone with you
in a room for a second to consume you
and then there'd be two of them or you
could spread apart into into little
pieces because remember each cell was
its own living creature it wasn't a
single unified creature it was like a
colony acting as a creature
yeah
you were a multicellular colony but you
know you chop the person's arm off their
arms and slither away and turn into
something else
you know so it was like a multicellular
colony acting like a
an individual yeah
well it's just kind of like [ __ ] that i
used to read about like
um
mushrooms for example which are like
fungus
and you only see like these little
mushrooms like popping up above the
surface
but underneath they're all like
interconnected so it's actually like one
big organism they say some of those
mushrooms are like the size of a state
yeah yeah which is crazy yeah that's
crazy they're all interconnected i
remember reading that and that like blew
my [ __ ] mind yeah because it's like
you just think of like oh it's a little
mushroom and it's another little
mushroom over there but it's like no
that's like all the same like from a dna
standpoint it's all one organism and it
can be like [ __ ] giant because all
the roots are like underneath
um i was gonna say something about
somebody asked about um
oh saunders said what is fake crab meat
made of fish yeah it's fish it's some
kind of white fish i don't know what
they make it out i think it's got it and
then they kind of like put like a little
dye thing on the end yeah it's just fish
that they've sent it through a processor
centrifuge grind it up into paste put it
in a centrifuge separated it out
and they cook it and dye it they flavor
it cook it and dye it just turn it into
it like a crab a crab flavored fish
product crab leg product
but it's still fish it's not like fake
or anything yeah it's fish
so it is still it's still delicious
a crabby taste to it yeah and it's all
protein it's it's good nutrition
and honestly i like it because you can
make crab salad out of it which i make
sandwiches with and you can also make
like sushi with it yeah you can't heat
it though no it's only good cold it's
good cold yeah although i will say that
koi wan buffet yeah they do a thing it's
like this weird what even what even is
it it's like a casserole it's
casserole's got it but it's like it's
like fake crab they do a crab salad too
which is actually pretty decent but they
do like it's fake crab and cheese yeah
and something else in there and that's
actually not bad and that's kind of like
heat it up it's pretty good there might
be some bread crumbs i kind of i think
there's like a crunchy crusty thing yeah
it's actually pretty good
but i don't like that crab heated
that fake crab
yeah i get that it is better it is
better much better i do really like like
crab salad though as long as i don't
like it if it's too goopy or mayonnaisy
yeah i like a little bit of mayonnaise
and some celery and
[ __ ] fake crab is a japanese invention
they eat a lot of that people don't
realize that that wasn't made for the
american market it just they just sold
it to us it's made for japan they eat a
[ __ ] out of it
i like sushi and stuff i know it's not
cool but i like it yeah
i don't know so so every now and then
like sam's sells like a big
like a plastic
thing of it
for
how much is it eight bucks seven bucks i
think no
yeah it's at six bucks something like
that yeah and uh so i like having like
some crab salad with it or like i said
we've made sushi with it a couple times
makes good sandwiches well we just had
we just like wrapped it we had the
sticky rice yeah and we put like
some
we put some fake crab meat in there we
put like a little bit of sour or cream
cheese in there
and a little bit of something else in
there
and like wrapped it all in seaweed with
the rice and everything and that was
actually pretty good maybe avocado what
the [ __ ] else would we put in there
mango mango badger he's [ __ ] uh that
mega yeah
that badgers uh down in there
flirting with sandra after i sh
after i showed you i showed them your
true form all of a sudden
they're a true form look at the size of
this thing
i showed wait what i just look at these
boobs
i should i showed sandra's true
porno pornographic form and all these
men are just just coming in and she goes
yeah i look just like that except for
the hair the face the eyes and the face
except for everything
omri vampire oh my god i haven't watched
you all live in so long
it's always 13 o'clock at my house when
i'm drinking vodka and listening to
jenny and tom that was [ __ ] well welcome
back
what we're all a bunch of alkies now
that's all right well we can't be alkies
like we don't
we just [ __ ] drink
i feel like there's a distinction to be
made between alkies which is bad uh and
drunks
i kind of feel we're we're more drunks
yeah sometimes but
well drunks you can just like do it when
you're out like having a good time or
you're hanging out like on the show yeah
because honestly other than being on the
show or if we're going out we don't
really drink all that much yeah social
drinkers like sometimes every now and
then like if we're just like hanging out
like watching a movie and we're not
going anywhere like we'll have one but
we don't like get drunk you know what i
mean the only time we really get drunk
is on this show or if we go out dancing
yeah
i feel like alcoholics are more like
i'm not like naming any names but there
was this woman actually i can't even
remember her name who dated my dad from
time
and
she always had
you know those little airplane bottles
of booze yeah she always had this in her
purse yeah and whenever there was like a
get-together she'd be like oh i'm gonna
go to the bathroom yeah she's drinking
it and then like she would come and then
like the more she would go to the
bathroom yeah
the more the night went on she would
come back and she'd be like i stopped
breaking right now yeah you see me like
that and i'm just like okay well we all
know what you're doing in there so it's
so that's an alcohol why did you just
put it in a flask and just be open about
it see i don't know
it's just that's classier to just go
ahead and go i'm gonna have to drank
them
i mean no one's as long as you're not
like starting any fights or like puking
on yourself or anything like that it's
like
you know it's fine
it's fine
or pooping yourself or whatever
getting sleepy are you sleeping already
how can that be
mango says i've been drunk since last
wednesday yeah i'm just well
the thing is like i i don't know
i don't know how old you are mango but
um you know i'm i'll be 49 next month
and
it's just being drunk is still fun it's
just that it takes way longer to recover
than it used to
i looked back even 10 years ago
and
it's like you know i used to go out
dancing all the time i wouldn't get
drunk drunk every night but i would
drink a lot and then it's like i'd get
up like at six o'clock the next morning
and like go to work and be mostly fine
um i can't imagine doing that now when
we first started hanging out we were
going we were going out almost every day
of the week we went out pretty much
every day it was ridiculous
and i wasn't that young no i was i was
42
yeah i think i was in my i was in my
late 30s yeah and so i mean but i mean i
didn't drink a lot during my teenage
years or my 20s you know a little bit
but not that much the clubs were funnier
fun more fun then though that's true
there's more people out it's dead right
now
i mean yeah it kind of is
but
yeah
yeah remember how fun it was
seems a lot bigger
yeah a lot of people well a lot of
people have gotten older like you got
old got fat won't come out anymore or
have other problems like have health
problems or they die like mike stone
died that's right friend of ours died a
couple days ago oh my god we didn't even
know we heard it we were walking to
memento on monday
and
the guy that owns like the guy and his
ghost owns the bar crosstalk he owns sly
fox it was like across the street yeah
and he said oh my god did you hear about
mike
and i was like no i didn't hear anything
about it like and i was like we just saw
him like a few months ago right i kind
of feel like we either saw him at a show
or we saw him at mannequins or something
oh yeah he died man he died like two
days ago
and on and like um remember [ __ ] ld
died yeah not too long ago he was gonna
die he was a well
but not like that
did he die car accident oh it's car
accident okay it was on i-4 okay someone
hit him ld was a dwarf and he had a
bunch of bunch of liver and kidney
problems we thought he was he thought he
was going to die anyway
but
well i think probably part of the reason
why he died in that accident being a
dwarf he had that damn van set up for
dwarf driving
and maybe he couldn't react fast enough
to something that happened well i don't
honestly i think he was just sitting on
an on-ramp and somebody and somebody
else's car and it was the middle of the
day it wasn't like the night time or
nothing like that and like this other
person like was driving and they just
like their car went out he was
physically frail though it probably
wouldn't have killed a healthy person he
was kind of physically i don't know i
don't know
what happened but that was like a while
back like ld used to um dj
at
momento mori's predecessor which was
called mitter knocked
um which they used to do yeah he was a
dwarf
yeah yeah i mean he had a lot of health
problems too right um but you know what
i mean so
yeah and then like a few months ago we
heard that like he died like on [ __ ]
i-4 which like i said
if you live in central florida i-4 is
the highway that goes from east coast
daytona beach uh to west coast tampa st
p clearwater area so it goes like across
you know the central part of the state
east west
and
it's better now than it used to be but
i4 is a [ __ ]
nightmare if you have to drive on it to
commute which i did for many years
everything
takes
forever
to get anywhere especially if it's like
daytime it's better now like since the
pandemic and they've done like a lot of
work on it they widened it and stuff so
it's better
but when i used to work because we live
in sanford which is like to the east of
downtown orlando and i used to work
west of downtown orlando
uh off on orange blossom trailer off of
orange blossom trail so
normally if there was no traffic maybe a
half hour drive it used to take me like
an hour and a half
to get to and from because
i-4
in
on weekdays was like a [ __ ] parking
lot it took
forever to get anywhere and there was
always accidents hugo says his favorite
show of ours was the moon landing and
the first time he that was the first
show he saw us in and we were drinking
so he started drinking and now he's
drinking now and we say he's blaming us
for his drinking problem we're
contributing we're contributing to
everyone's alcoholism yeah the moonland
sorry well we didn't honestly when we
first started the show i think for the
first several years yeah we didn't
really drink on the show did we
i think we only started doing that like
when we started live streaming and we
didn't start live streaming until our
200th episode yeah which was several
years in yes the moon landing was real
yeah yes stanley kubrick didn't do that
[ __ ] no his middle name was real
[Laughter]
i told you guys already my granddad
helped [ __ ] build that damn saturn v
rocket
it went it left and it [ __ ] came back
they built a bunch of other ones and
they went several times my grandfather
worked for that for nasa as well yeah he
was an electrician at the time i think i
think he was he was working for nasa i
think at the time but
but i think he was being contracted out
by grumman aerospace at the time he was
in a bunch of those aerospace companies
he did a lot of [ __ ] weird [ __ ] some
of it out some of it
somebody couldn't talk about but but he
could talk about the saturn project
the other one was for a company that he
worked with for a while
it's declassified now
it was
he worked for a company that was
subcontracting for a company called
general atomics
and they were building a nuclear-powered
spacecraft called the orion
and he was on the orion project and a
bunch of weird [ __ ] had happened there
but
i didn't hear that from him i heard this
from my uncle
and [ __ ] he didn't tell anything he
didn't say anything about orion during
his during his life because orion was
still classified i think up until about
the time he died
you ever heard about the orion i've
heard about it but yeah but see every
time you say orion i always think of
like the elvis
impersonator yeah
the reason why they didn't want to talk
about orion is because it involved
[ __ ] nuclear bombs about the size of
a [ __ ] ping-pong ball
and they learned how to make an atomic
bomb an atomic bomb about the size of a
ping-pong ball that was cheap and easy
to make and that engine would drop about
two or three of them a second out the
back of it the engine was just a coke
bottling machine could throw them out
real fast
and it would pass a [ __ ] magnetic
field which would arm them and they were
timed and then they'd blow up behind a
plate
and that
[ __ ] thing was the size of a [ __ ]
40
probably 20 20 foot tall building it
weighed about what a wait about what a
submarine would weigh
it was made out of steel there was
nothing [ __ ] effeminate about this
[ __ ] spacecraft it was like moving a
damn monument everything was made to be
as big and heavy and as strong as
possible what would an effeminate well
an effeminate [ __ ] be thin ass
[ __ ] aluminum like it could be made
of like lace yeah yeah thin aluminum
lightweight none of that [ __ ] this [ __ ]
was made to be heavy as possible because
uh it had to be real heavy to exp to
survive all these forces it's made out
of menstrual blood no it's made of
[ __ ]
certain [ __ ] parts of the nose was
made out of [ __ ] poured concrete and
[ __ ] cast iron they tried to get [ __ ]
as heavy as possible because they had
all the power they needed
to get it into orbit they were going to
launch it off a damn platform out in the
pacific ocean
would be bad and it would be able to get
to [ __ ] be able to get to mars in
like three weeks it could get to saturn
in a month
or jupiter in a month
that's how fast it was
camp guys said my elementary school was
made out of solid cinder blocks um a lot
of old houses and buildings in florida
are also made out of solid cinder blocks
or poured concrete that was another
thing too well you know we have to keep
like hurricanes from launch it away um
tila says atomic bombs the size of a
ping-pong ball dudes are so evil yeah
it's like
seriously like use your smarts like for
something that
is like you know helps people what was
[ __ ] a spacecraft engine yeah okay it
wasn't a weapon it was going to use it
on space space yeah but you know how
that would go you know how that would go
and then um
it was uh
it could accelerate so hard that you
could get
from earth
all the way out to damn jupiter and
still have one g of acceleration so
everyone would be
like they had gravity that's how they
wouldn't be all like they would never
been against like they were like never
liking the gravitron they would never be
weightless they would always be at one g
and then on the deceleration run they'd
flip it around backwards and the
deceleration make a stick they turn
around backwards you stick to the floor
because you were decelerating
so you were never it was it was it had
enough power to give that kind of
acceleration the whole way you get
you're getting the [ __ ] jupiter in
about three months i think they said it
was three months
badass with no computers
just [ __ ] white boys and [ __ ]
white shirts and neckties and [ __ ]
slide rulers
with a [ __ ] pencil in their mouth
looking out the window
that was that that was bad we had bad
ass white blood like [ __ ] ties
[ __ ] pocket puts a pocket protector
and a tie give me get my pen we'll be
there in about three months captain okay
put push it push the nose over a little
bit
and they're looking through the dead
yeah that that we'll be there in time
okay yeah we'll get i can't imagine like
the balls it would take to just be like
well we're going off into space we just
like clutched this thing together yeah
yeah entirely sure we know we're doing
pointed out that way [ __ ] put the
steam on it [ __ ] jupiter will
probably be in line when we get there
probably yeah it'll be around there
we'll adjust it if we have yeah we'll
adjust it we'll adjust it in the final
few days yeah [ __ ] right
they were crazy
and yeah yeah they were crazy but you
can't land on jupiter anyway because
it's all slushy they were gonna go to
those moons
yeah that's true they were gonna go to
the moons
but the uh they wanted to go to like
titan and everything
and but they were gonna uh
they were gonna go
and [ __ ] they were nuts man they were
gonna like take their families with them
because they didn't have weight
restrictions
that's how much power it had so we're
gonna take like women and children with
them come on kids could be like yeah
come on get in we're going to jupiter
yeah
a very very positive thinking man that's
some alpha [ __ ] thinking that's some
alpha [ __ ] well the technology was
very simple it was just a coke bottling
machine and they had two of them well
another one has a backup and it had
mechanics on there to fix it if anything
went wrong
and then um it had a nuclear power plant
and it would generate all the all the
electrical power you needed the nuclear
power plant was out of submarine
so it was all tried and true materials
you know
or you know it wasn't anything
experimental it was just
the secret was that damn
atomic pellets about the size of a
ping-pong ball they were in something
about the size of a soup can to make
them easier to deal with they'd shoot
them out
i think two or three of a second you can
just pour the [ __ ] power on the more
power you put on it's all mechanical the
more of them it would throw out the back
they went through a magnetic field
yeah and that's so like jewels burn
jules vern [ __ ] but it would have worked
it was yeah i'm just saying that they
went over that [ __ ] over and over again
that all the math was sound and it would
work they wanted to know the blast it
threw him out of the back of a blast
plate that was on this big [ __ ] it
was a huge
cast iron black
blast plate on the back that had shock
absorbers
okay
and they wanted to
know how many microns of [ __ ] erosion
was there on the back of that plate per
explosion so how many explosions would
that thing last for
and if i remember like on top of my head
going to
going to jupiter and back
you really would have only lost a few
feet
of thickness off of this blast plate and
that blast plate was [ __ ] 10 15 feet
thick so you know
it would have lasted a long time
you could change it too change it out i
don't know jupiter would be my first
destination yeah they were gonna go
there first we're gonna go to mars first
because that was short it was like only
a few weeks away
they were gonna put putt all around
what killed it if kennedy killed it
because the air force says we want three
of them and we want them with nuclear
cannons on them
and and they went yeah we can do that
they were going to make death stars
basically
remember it's like no
yeah they want they want them like it's
not they wanted cannons on them like a
battleship they could launch
a time nuclear war letting
five-year-olds run [ __ ]
that's when men ran [ __ ] right
and uh also can have like a giant tiger
with green
and give him a machine gun the only
five-year-old boys ranchers
[Laughter]
beautiful man it's beautiful that's when
men said [ __ ] dropping nuts we're
going to make a death star
but kennedy saw
yeah the [ __ ] air force wanted three
of them
and i think the army wanted something or
the air force wanted some too we
accidentally okay i got to have one too
well i gotta have that i also would like
to go to now so they were gonna have
like five or six of them just orbiting
around
earth the whole time it's like orbital
and nuclear platforms new orbital
nuclear battleships is what they were
basically
and they were going to have [ __ ] the
ability to [ __ ]
shoot dudes out through the cannons into
orbit and come down in parachutes of
course
so you could you could you could insert
commandos through from high orbit and
[ __ ] they were crazy but it was totally
brilliant [ __ ] right
[Laughter]
shoot some commandos down there
concurring them in through orbit and
everything we're gonna [ __ ] you up
they're gonna burn it in through the
atmosphere you know
hell yeah you jump out of the [ __ ]
once you once once you slowed down
enough and and re-entered you could then
jump out of the capsule and hit a
parachute [ __ ] come down hit the ground
with your little nine-millimeter
sub-machine gun shoot some [ __ ]
and then you get shot at me
[Laughter]
it was just the thinking was like yeah
whatever the thinking was very
testosterone enriched you know come back
it was really good
but they were going to have like five of
these some would say testosterone
impaired but no you're rich
but they were going to have like five of
them around death stars basically and
kennedy saw that and goes man the
russians are going to [ __ ] if they
he canceled it they're literally gonna
[ __ ] yeah
they probably would have the russians
might have launched if they saw that
[ __ ] well yeah and i'm sure like
kennedy's probably like yeah let's not
let's not i don't want to get nuked um
most people don't want to get news and
they made it they made a non
they made a treaty not to nuclearize
space
with the soviets
but the soviets are gone which means you
could do it
we didn't make that agreement with
russia
so if anybody wants to get on that
field's wide open the big the big
downside of it is that the thing was
designed to be launched
from the earth's surface out in the
ocean
it left a lot of radioactivity behind
not a lot i mean it was equivalent to a
couple of
a-bomb tests above the surface they did
those all the time
but it would have been you know if you
never had any problem during the launch
you would have dropped a lot of damn
nuclear pellets into the ocean you know
somebody might want to try to go down
there and go get them
it'd be a lot safer if you could uh
assemble something like that in orbit
i think
so you have to launch it through the
atmosphere
and that elon mess musk ship could do
that but you put the damn nuclear drive
on there you'll actually be able to go
somewhere this [ __ ]
liquid fuel rocket that's for [ __ ]
you'll never get enough speed
you're gonna need nuclear power man
you could get like one tenth the speed
of light with [ __ ] with that that
system that's fast
very fast
sorry they're talking about talk about
clotted cream yeah
that's clotted green
clotted cream
what's that it's like it's this
delicious concoction they put on scones
in the uk okay with strawberry jam yeah
it's super super delicious
um
yeah
i just i remember having that like on a
[ __ ]
flight over there
somebody said something what are you
guys talking about jaffa cakes i don't
like those as much i would say like i
will say the british do have like some
good snacks but
uh october race is dead kennedy's
man i love i love the [ __ ] dead
kennedys
they say i'm gonna take my hat off to
unveil my uncle fester wig yeah let's
not go faster wig
that's his real head though
that's his real head like see he doesn't
have all the hair that was on his head
like migrated down to his back and i had
to shave yeah he had to shave it off
um
yeah tammy said why the hell are peeps
trying to go to different planets and
stuff is mcdonald's on saturn yeah i
think i would i wouldn't mind going to
another planet but i'm not going to be
the first to go to another planet
because that'd be [ __ ] lame i'm not
going up there like [ __ ] camping
like i'm gonna wait till like other
people go and like build some [ __ ] so i
can you know relax yeah but other than
that i'm not reverse well there's some
pretty interesting [ __ ] though
saturn and jupiter have some moons that
are pretty interesting
um i think there's one around saturn
it's a real cold one i don't remember
the name of that [ __ ]
it might have been titan that's not
tight i kind of i kind of wish that like
the moon was called that [ __ ] that
[ __ ] yeah i'm gonna have a moon
[Laughter]
that [ __ ] right there
it's gonna be called that [ __ ]
yeah
but uh one of them i think it might have
been one around saturn maybe you guys
can correct me they think there might be
life on it
but not like super cool like party life
no like like you know
sub-atomic animals boring ass
bacterial life i'm sure yeah but it
would be weird because it's real cold
there they'd be living in like [ __ ]
liquid hydrogen or something but see
like i said that's not weird nowadays
because now they have those
extremophiles right that's like all this
the liver on like heat vents like
underneath the [ __ ] ocean and all
that kind of they got a video of it man
there was a landing the lander that went
there and it was coming down through the
atmosphere it's got it looks like the
damn grand canyon
and it landed in a
like a sandy boggy looking looks like
look like a sand bar
and it hit pop like that and stuck and
sunk down a little bit it's a couple
inches deep
and it um but it wasn't water it was i
think a liquid hydrogen i think
or was or liquid helium or something it
was it's so cold that gases are liquid
liquids there you know but it looked
like water
it looks like you could step out and
just walk off it's not though that's
[ __ ] yeah oh i wouldn't advise it
like several hundred degrees below zero
you know
danny rolling ghost bay says i'm
surprised they never made an earnest
goes to space or earnest meets the
aliens did they not make an earnest goes
to space because i
could have sworn they made an earnest
goes to space he's dead i can't believe
we're talking about that guy he's dead
now right i don't know jim verney
i'm pretty sure he died i never saw any
of those movies i don't think i did
either but um i mean i saw like clips of
them but i could have sworn they did in
a space one he was supposed to be like a
shakespearean actor evidently i think he
wait was he yeah right i'm gonna have to
look back that's not what he was known
for i mean he got known for that those
commercials but that's
no it was commerce it was movies
he started out in commercials i remember
his vern
yeah
yeah it started like commercials and for
whatever reason that just like struck
some like cultural accord yeah i don't
know why it was like we're gonna make
like a and honestly they made like more
movies than i was even like aware of i
think he was from mississippi somebody
might check him but but i think i
remember ernest goes to jail
ernest scared stupid i remember that one
i might have seen that
i never saw him they probably sucked
i don't know i haven't i can't really
say but i could have sworn there was a
space one but maybe not
that seemed like a
a giant missed opportunity [ __ ] man even
jason voorhees went to space
[Laughter]
he's like a cyber jason oh my god did
you guys know that did you guys see that
it was like so that was jason x right
was it jason x yeah 10. they didn't call
it like jason goes to space no but it
was just kind of like when he was frozen
in time yeah
he'd been like cryogenically frozen
i saw it
a long time ago i don't entirely
remember what happened did it
but he was like a cyborgie
i don't know it was ridiculous
but not like not ridiculous
i don't know i wanted it to be more
ridiculous
i think i kind of watched it and i was
like i wish this was stupider
like i think i would have enjoyed it
more
because it was stupid but it wasn't
stupid enough for me to like enjoy it
you know what i'm saying
it's just bad
it's interesting because that was the
kind of [ __ ] that [ __ ] uh minnie me
would like
yeah yeah he'd see that [ __ ] and he'd be
like [ __ ] oh it's this great movie dude
i saw this great movie you ever heard of
you ever heard of you ever heard of a
[ __ ] movie called friday the 13th
oh you have okay yeah it's friday the
13th 10. okay it's about these guys on
this [ __ ] space station all right and
and and they got this dude in the cocky
basket
and he's killing them all they got
really hot girls in it man you'd love it
oh it's great oh it's got a really good
story well he was super into the whole
you remember when like the halloween
series went into that whole thing with
like the
yeah always possessed by a demon or the
yeah
whatever deep is [ __ ] he thought that
[ __ ] was dying i remember being over
there like at me and you were over at
his apartment one time and him going
into this big long thing about him like
explain where like or could it be
that the that those halloween movies
just sucked yeah just you know think
about that now he thought that she was
real deep
i don't know like like i said and you
know and i can't judge because i'm like
i overthink everything i get but
sometimes
um a stupid movie is just a stupid movie
and he was talking about the uh the rob
zombie one i think wasn't he
oh god please tell me he wasn't no
because i don't think that would come
it was one of the last i think it was it
was one of the later ones to be honest
it wasn't one of the it wasn't one of
the the uh um
uh what it wasn't like one or two
it wasn't part one or two it was like no
he was talking about the later sequels
yeah where it went into like a more
supernatural direction that wasn't the
right rob zombie that was like the total
like reboot all right
honestly i have to say and i like rob
zombie i'm not like [ __ ] a rob
zombie but
um you know i liked most like his
movies that he made because and he's
super into horror movies and you know we
love that
but
i will say that his remake of halloween
was one of the only movies that i ever
almost walked out of yeah because i was
just kind of like why why rob zombie
somebody that is that into horror
you should know
that
over explaining your villain
is a big no-no leaves like some mystery
everybody likes to have everybody like
michael myers sandra says sounds like
little tom his name it wasn't that
little time was minnie b that's what we
called him yeah we're not saying what
his real name is can't be any farther
away from the real time characterized no
uh he was
he was very far away i think and like i
said i'm you know i'm guilty of like you
know i like to overthink things like i
said i'm super in horror too i'm a nerd
about it and everything but it's like
i'm
i don't take myself that seriously
um and i know when something's just like
crappy and you can read [ __ ] into stuff
but a lot of stuff i don't think was
intended no right and honestly like the
the later halloween sequels
i don't really think i think they were
just kind of like well um
at this point like he never gets killed
so he must be like a demon of some kind
so we have to like write that into the
show i don't think they were like
thinking about it no it wasn't like this
big yeah it wasn't like this big deep
thing it was just like a cash grab it
was the same thing with the friday the
13th they just had to make another movie
because the last one did well it's like
oh well let's kill them
let's go to manhattan on this oh let's
go to space yeah
they do the same thing like in every
[ __ ] franchise that goes on that long
you run out of ideas and then you just
start doing stupid [ __ ] it was a joke
you just started doing stupid [ __ ] it
doesn't mean anything they didn't have
like any continuity or anything like
that
no
well they were obviously trolling they
were trolling and the whole thing was a
[ __ ] joke they were trolling even
back in the early 80s
yeah they're like well let's see how
stupid we can make something and like i
don't think they were like legit
thinking this but it's like in some ways
they're like well let's just use this
dumb ass idea and like maybe people will
see it like just
well what do you talk about on friday
13th yeah and friday the 13th what it
was is that we know that we basically
killed him in the last one but he's back
okay just [ __ ] deal with it well they
haven't well the thing about it
you're working on the friday the 13th
series i mean you're not a millionaire
yeah um you know it's just somebody
that's like okay well we know we killed
him in the last one like definitively
but you bought a ticket but
we have to make another movie because
they make money so yeah here you go
think of something yeah so it's like
look like i said i'm a horror writer so
i know you give it to some screenwriter
that's just like looking for a paycheck
right and he's like well [ __ ] um let's
see i don't know demons aliens what do
you have to think of like some
supernatural reason why this [ __ ] keeps
coming back to life that almost didn't
happen in friday the 13th though
they did yeah i'm just saying
in general in general it was just a it
was just a it was just a nod and a wink
it's honestly probably better to look
like not yeah it was just not even
explaining it it was better it's just as
a nod
come to your own conclusions right
you paid for the ticket you wanted more
we're going to show you more that's all
it was
and yeah yeah he comes back all the time
and freddie was like that and [ __ ]
they're all like that but the thing
about that [ __ ] will give you more of
this the thing about freddy though was
that at least and i'll give you a dream
yeah at least he was supernatural from
the beginning because he was like he was
a dead dude yeah and he was just coming
back in people's dreams so he was
already supernatural from the jump i
kind of feel like halloween
and friday the 13th that's kind of a
different animal because
both of those killers were set up as
human
slashers
from the beginning like there wasn't
really any that much indication that
they were supernatural in any fashion
freddy was supernatural from the outset
so you know the crazier that that got
and like i said it got like stupid and
went into comedy later which you know i
didn't love that but they did kind of
like recover it though with like the you
know with wes craven's new nightmare and
stuff where they like went meta with it
and i think that was a good idea
but because you know what are you gonna
do with that that's what we're talking
about t we're talking about the series
that just go on and on and on that [ __ ]
was all just a nod in a wink they knew
that you just wanted to see another
movie they didn't have to explain it
and honestly they did explain and it got
[ __ ] worse
if you go see friday like halloween to a
lesser extent okay because i know
there's like a whole extended mythos
with that but friday the 13th
i mean basically all you're going you're
just going to see jason kill people in
like creative and gory ways and somebody
survive and the way and the you know as
long as you can facilitate that in a way
that people are just like okay whatever
um then that's fine so you don't have to
like overthink it when it came to that
to those kind of slasher franchises
in
overall i'd say that
friday 13th was the best one
because it didn't try to be something
that it wasn't
it was obviously [ __ ] with you it was
obviously giving you what you wanted it
obviously did not give any rational
explanations for any of this [ __ ]
you it was just pure entertainment
they knew you were a kid
and you were
at you rented this [ __ ] on [ __ ] vhs
and chances are
you're like a high school [ __ ] soft
sophomore yeah you're like down in the
basement with some beers and some pizza
or you or
have mia's down with like cheryl or some
[ __ ] like that or some [ __ ] girl and
you're gonna get blown that's right
it's just you gotta have something
rolling
so you get a little job
you're gonna grab some titties
yeah
because you know you're too young she's
not gonna let you in not yet yeah she's
probably still a virgin it's gonna be
you fighting through that hymen you know
you know you're
fighting your way through that hymen
wall you know what i mean you're not
gonna get any give me some [ __ ] like
that you know you guys know how it is
like she's laughing
[Laughter]
fighting behind
no no no no no
you didn't do the loophole you didn't go
up the butt no no no no no no because
that was like that was that was way too
advanced for me at that time okay it
would have been way too advanced i feel
like that's something that like a lot of
catholic school kids did yeah i don't
know but back about back then but like
nobody's like well it's technically not
sex if you're going in the butt because
it's not you know no we we weren't we
weren't off into that yet maybe some
people were i didn't hear anything about
it we were just lucky to get some head
[ __ ] i was reading billy otto's book
that you gave me he said you you're back
in england and everything [ __ ] the
main thing there was just get a hand job
puck rock girls giving you hand jobs
back in the 70s
they go out in the back of the club and
give you hand jobs been back back in the
alley
says they would they wouldn't give head
though
they wouldn't give any ass either
couldn't get in but he was like underage
so were they though
yeah you know nobody kind of wants
tila says thanks for reminding me of
losing my virginity tom not the best
memory yeah yeah yeah
fight your way through that wall
i kind of feel like i i don't you know i
don't want to speak for all women
everywhere
i do kind of feel like for most women
losing their virginity is probably not a
good experience
yeah yeah because it was probably like
you know you're probably popping back
well you were probably
you were probably very young yeah um
you're probably with a dude who was
equally young and had no idea what he
was doing
so
you know it probably wasn't a good
experience i you know i i would be
interested to hear from like any you
know girls that it was a good experience
but i don't think most girls had a good
experience
their first time i did most of the time
i'd
everybody anyone said it wasn't
you know what i'm saying yeah [ __ ] my
junior and junior senior year [ __ ]
probably half of them were virgins
you couldn't get it
you could get everything else but
you couldn't get the ass though but it's
just all oral and [ __ ]
that's good enough though while you were
watching friday the 13th and one time i
senior year you [ __ ] i actually
[ __ ] got one to give it up that was
in brazil
i was in brazil
yeah
that's pretty funny she was older than
me memories yeah tom like always hitting
the older women
well not by much only like a year or two
that doesn't even count yeah that age no
that doesn't count
well you think she's oh boy she does
she's she's two years older than me well
yeah i mean when you're that age yeah
she's out of high school seems like
she's a grown woman she's out of high
school well that's kind of like how all
the high school girls wanted to go out
with like college dudes yeah yeah right
yeah because it seemed like a huge
difference to go like college dudes oh
they're so much more mature yeah either
not really because dudes don't get
mature until they're 45. yeah if if if
they have
yeah
if if they're gonna mature yeah some of
them are like it happens
honestly
most of the time i'm probably not uh
because like i said i do kind of feel
like dudes are like perpetually yeah 10
year olds
but you know that's that's just me
saying that
no offense
damn you wanted a drink yeah why not
should i make it weaker yeah make a
weaker one
yeah i'm having a good time though all
right
i don't want to talk all night though
man i want to get something to eat in a
bit i know but you're it's not even
three hours calm down
glowing turtle says watch cocaine
cowboys great suggestion thank you yeah
we really enjoyed it as well that's some
like [ __ ] crazy ass [ __ ]
uh sandra says you have that strange
rule in the u.s that you have to have
sex at the third date at least all the
teenage movies say so
um
i don't know i don't feel like um
it's not like a hard and fast rule
honestly i feel like nowadays i i don't
even know like because i've been out of
the dating pool for a while but
i feel like there's like really no rules
people just like do whatever which i
think is kind of like better
even when i was in high school i don't
really remember
i don't remember a lot of like
i don't know i don't really remember a
lot of like rules per se people just did
whatever they felt like doing
and i felt like most people i knew in
high school
um that we're dating we're banging
i mean you know what i mean i ca you
know and it wasn't really that big a
thing and like i said this was
late 80s
so
i don't know i don't know if it was a
thing
sandra's saying that like a lot of us
teen movies so there's like this rule
where you have to have sex on the third
date
oh no i've heard that but i don't know
if that on the ground i don't really
think that's a thing that's like a movie
thing
you know that just says this is a great
show
[Laughter]
now there wasn't a rule like that
no yeah like i said it's no i kind of
felt like everybody even back then and
nowadays people just do whatever they
[ __ ] feel like doing yeah and we also
kind of had different rules about what
sex was if everybody was coming it was
sex it didn't matter if you actually did
it or not you know what i mean
like in uh
at least up until you about your your
your senior year your senior year in
high school is redefined no you're gonna
get in that [ __ ] then that
that's that's the real thing you know
penetration there has to be penetration
again and and that's kind of but you
were you know come on man your your
sophomore and junior year you were lucky
to get any action you're lucky
get up
you felt lucky at least
yeah
in those days
but like i said you know just
remembering back to my thing is is that
we were dating a lot
yeah well yeah everybody was so
if you got into one you'd have to go
steady you couldn't date anybody else
but if you're just gonna make out and
[ __ ] get each other off and [ __ ] you
could jump around
it was like not a commitment yeah
because like you're playing a field i do
kind of feel like it's not so much a
rule but i do kind of feel like back in
the old days yeah if you actually right
if you just did like oral [ __ ] and
seriously then it was like okay you
could do it and it wasn't like a big
deal but like yeah if you actually had
sex with that person like you penetrated
just stay with her then yeah that was
kind of like a much bigger deal right
like i don't think it meant that you had
to stay with that person but it was like
a much bigger day you couldn't date
anybody else and you see we were dating
we would date
sometimes different girls every every
week
you do one one week and then do another
one another week and you go back to that
one so you might date like three or four
of them at once
but you're not having sex with them
technically
technically
[Laughter]
grandparents was there man he'll tell
you he was in the same [ __ ] path i
haven't seen him in the chat yeah i
don't think he's here actually
you know what i mean right uh yeah
so we were dudes we were trying to
[ __ ] we were trying to find loopholes
you know thomas
well that's what i mean that was that
was why that whole anal sex thing is a
loophole for like yeah but we're trying
to find a loophole to where we could
date we could we could spread it around
can you talk about it well it's like
well i still want to have sex with her
but i want to have sex with all the
girls yeah right without any are you
trying to figure out what that's kind of
like dude's whole
thing well you're young and you're
trying to figure out you know what you
like and what you don't like and what's
this girl like what you also there's
just this driving [ __ ] fascination at
that age of [ __ ] finding out exactly
what they look like without clothes on
you want to know what they look like see
i feel like you still kind of think that
though yeah i think it's just normal
instinct but you just
you just want to know what they look
like without clothes on and then you
[ __ ] say i saw her without her
clothes are man i know exactly what she
looks like you know
and you guys are comparing notes yeah
she looks good that's
it yeah yeah because we weren't we
weren't jealous
tila said apparently there is a book
called the rules oh yeah
um i haven't read it i've read like
portions of it
but
yeah i kind of feel like maybe that was
like 90s or early 2000s i feel like
there was this kind of like trend
of
books for people that it's like oh we're
dating and this is what you do ladies
uh they're mostly like geared toward
women i think where they were just kind
of like you have to do x y and z and you
had like all these [ __ ] and honestly
anything like that i hate anything like
that i hate anything
that's just kind of like well in this
situation you do xyz because it's like
every single person is different every
single situation is different you can't
like just
go down a checklist
and be like well if he says this then do
this i just think that's really like
reductive normies do that that's what i
mean it's just to me that just seems
very irritating
um and it just takes all the spontaneity
and fun out of everything
it's like jenny so sometimes here on
this show
[ __ ] people have asked me questions
about jenny and [ __ ] and i go no
jenny is not like dating the average one
is your average woman she's like no
really really yeah no
no big differences
back when i was
back in my 20s and [ __ ] 20s and 30s
like in
the average woman was big into cosmo
magazine and she'd been reading all
kinds of [ __ ] about dudes they
played these games like what they're
talking about it was just real
kind of normie mundane kind of ways of
looking at it i hate that everything was
just like a certain and there there
wasn't any uh
wasn't much game to them
wasn't much um there wasn't any kind of
natural flow
but what was funny is that sometimes
i might fall in with somebody like that
and they'd be real impressed with me
because i wasn't doing normal mundane
kind of [ __ ]
like i thought that was very interesting
you know what i mean because evidently
there i wasn't
i'm pretty much not like the average guy
you didn't fall into one of the
prescribed
categories
but then but then they a lot of those
women kind of naturally kind of had a
manipulative streak in them so they were
trying to get some kind of result out of
me in front of their friends
and this [ __ ] didn't work out i don't
play those kind of games see well i
don't like that in anybody right men or
women right um i'm always just kind of
like dude just be what you're like
um either either i think you're cool or
i think you're an [ __ ] it's just like
but don't pretend to be something you're
not
don't like go and i there's a lot of
problems too because you know and if we
ever do a show about like the in-cell
community or anything like that i kind
of feel like there's a large strain of
that in there too because they kind of
feel like oh well i did xyz
and i didn't get you know i didn't get
this result right and i'm like yeah
because that's not how humans work right
well they're okay that's a good way of
putting it there are a lot of women that
are female equivalents of that that's
what i mean it's just kind of like like
there was some of them that i [ __ ]
would run into over the years especially
in boston back in the 90s and boston was
extremely [ __ ] superficial
um
they do weird [ __ ] like i get the
feeling that
this chick wants me
to put a ring on her finger and make a
commitment to her in front of her
friends here at this dinner table so
everyone else can see and so she can so
there's like this big convoluted
thing
that only happens in the in in in the
mind of a woman
that's that you know what i mean
well and you know and i will give you
that
women she saw on friends or on school
well no not necessarily because because
women are a lot more socially adept i
will say in general uh not always but
they are a lot more socially they are a
lot more attuned to
social cues they are a lot more attuned
to community in general than men are so
a lot of times
you know a lot of the stuff that they do
is for particular reasons
um you know not so much because it's
like oh i want to look good in front of
my friends but also to like avoid
humiliation to avoid because they know
how other women are going to think about
them so it's like this whole
complication yeah that's a good way to
put it always it always seemed like it
had to do with other women
yeah well there is kind of like a big
because women see other women in a
different way than they see and you know
it's the same the other way around like
men don't see women the way other women
see right you know because you always
have to end up going to dinner with her
and her girlfriends
and and the girlfriend is judging you
like
like [ __ ]
she's her mom or some weird [ __ ] but but
like i said that's extreme normally
normie stuff
and and what what was the sad truth of
the whole thing back in that era
is that uh every time i was put in that
position
um i already knew there'd be no future
to that relationship i was just there to
get the ass
well and the thing too is that i mean i
it's kind of hard for us because we grew
up in you know the goth subculture
which has completely a honestly
different completely different set of
norms right i guess so it's kind of like
having been in that since you know i was
very young right i understand that there
are other norms for regular people and i
you know i kind of know of them just
from afar
but i never really experienced that to
any great degree because i wasn't ever
from subjected to that from our point of
view your end uh it feels like you've
been transported backwards to another
time
to some [ __ ] ancient proc
some ancient [ __ ]
province
of [ __ ] i don't know northumbria or
somewhere well everything seems and it's
all kind of fake and artificial yeah
that's how it all seemed to me it's like
everything i was like why can't you guys
just like act like [ __ ] normal like
act like what like just do what you want
or be how you want like i don't
understand why there has to be this
whole like rigmarole yeah and then
everything is a it's about future
orientation you know what i mean about
[ __ ] well
this is where we are now in life but
where will you be 10 15 years from now
in your career and what will our
relationship be so it's all this
overthinking [ __ ]
coming from them you know what i mean
what are my friends going to think of
you in 20 years that kind of weird [ __ ]
now like i said no i'm not that's what
they were this is what that was dealing
with but i'm looking just going i'll
tell you what you look great in those
jeans i'm just going to try to get it
well that's the only thing that i was
really but to be honest with you i'm not
i am going to like defend that to a
little to a small degree because
um like i said for women it's not you
have a lot more to lose yeah um you know
in the sense that you could get pregnant
you could get you know there's a lot of
things that can happen to you so you
have to be a lot more circumspect right
about
is this dude like if he knocks me up for
example because it could happen and it's
happened to me
um you know
is he gonna like stick around do i have
like a future with this person so it's
like you have to so women are a lot more
practical um than men in in the long
term
so you can't get you can't [ __ ] on them
too much for just thinking about
you know is this dude just gonna like
bang me and never call me again and then
like what if i turn it pregnant what if
i get an std what if this is that the
other so it's like a lot of things that
you have to like um you know what if he
stalks me for christ's sake because i've
had that happen too so it's kind of like
there's a lot more factors that we have
to uh you know so so you can't just
women don't really have the luxury of
just like banging somebody and like
forgetting about it
um you know it's better now that it used
to be obviously but
you don't have as much leeway in that
sense so i do understand
women that you know think about those
type of things because you do have to
think about those type of things because
like i said you have a lot of um
things that you have to consider that
men don't um
but on the other hand uh you do have a
thing where
you
you know i like i said i tell you what
jenny that girl i guarantee you had put
10 dudes before me through that and
probably 50 dudes after me through that
and she never got [ __ ] she never got
lucky
using that approach
dudes don't respond to that approach
they'll just move on to somebody well
you can't come on too strong in that
yeah and see where you're you're you're
a suitor
bachelor and they're already sizing you
up for marriage and it's just
guys are not thinking at that level
it takes
it takes time for that to [ __ ]
develop especially at a guy in his
twenties it's not going to happen
yeah it was another era and that's what
i was saying too about that's why like
guys don't really mature until now
especially if you're dealing with
younger guys right um yes i understand
like i said women have a lot more
considerations right but um but you
can't expect 22 year old woman that was
looking for that needs to be going out
with looking at guys in their [ __ ]
early 40s eight ladies yeah you can't
really expect that from their 20s
because it's like they're not gonna they
don't give a [ __ ] they're gonna
constantly disappoint you yeah yeah i'm
just telling you that that is not
that is not the priorities of the
[ __ ] guys in their 20s
because they don't have any material
wealth they don't have a career to worry
about if they do have a career it's a
very fledgling beginnings of a career
like i said they don't have to worry
about getting pregnant or getting
saddled with a kid or anything like that
[ __ ] to get married they can't afford
to [ __ ] have children they can't
afford any of that [ __ ] they're they're
just looking to have a good time and
really
um they they don't really have anything
to offer most of them yeah but you know
so
they're you're not gonna [ __ ] get the
whole bachelor experience out of those
[ __ ] it's not gonna happen
but they're but women are taught in that
era and at least in that generation
were taught to expect that which was a
totally unrealistic explanation a
totally unrealistic [ __ ] um
expectation from dudes in their 20s in
the 1990s no wouldn't happen
yeah you just can't and like i said it's
sad but the old guys had all the money
young guys had nothing
and it's that's really to say that's the
way it is now
young guys of today have [ __ ] nothing
well and like i said as long as and i
kind of feel like it's it's better now
because you have less of this stigma
about
young women they're like look i'm just
going to go out and bang a hot dude and
like not call him again well because
that's what dudes have been doing for
like generations right so i kind of feel
like i'm glad that like women can now
kind of do that and there's not like a
stigma about it they're just like yeah
[ __ ] him whatever right so because like
i said that's kind of riding that [ __ ]
carousel
yeah well those dudes don't have
anything to offer anyway that's what i
mean
that's all they have
you know might as well have some fun
while you're young a guy is lucky to
have some [ __ ] by the time he's 40.
that's the very top 10
yeah of the dudes have something at 40.
[ __ ] if you look at how dudes
statistically if you look at how dudes
are doing even here in the united states
they're doing pretty bad especially the
young ones
well there's really not a lot going on
well it's sad because you can't really
make that much money no and honestly
i've kind of heard about because there's
no stable careers because i have younger
siblings and it's like um you know it's
not too bad for them but it's like you
know some you know my like my youngest
brother is actually an electrician um
but he has a house with his wife and
stuff but it's like a lot of people his
age
um you know can't afford to buy a house
and we'll probably never be able to
afford to buy a house which is like
really really sad you know what i mean
um
not like i can afford to buy a house
because i can't either and i'm like
almost 50. but you know what i mean it's
it's
tom left my ass and i don't know what
you're laughing at bro just to give the
context guys october 8 says i love this
show oh thanks you guys we're having a
good time actually i'm having a good
time but yeah it's just kind of like i
don't know i'm fascinated though
this is why one of these days we have to
do a show about the incels i don't know
i think i put it oh my god we got
answers on the list right i
yeah it's on it's in the poll this week
i don't know if it's gonna win i gotta
check on sunday um because i think i put
it in the poll but the poll doesn't go
up till friday and then like you know
the poll ends on sunday
so
i kind of want to do a show about that
because
or maybe it was in the poll last week
and it didn't win or something like that
but eventually we'll get to it
that kind of [ __ ] fascinates it
fascinates me
how
um
those type of dudes see
i mean they just seem so like
transactional that was like one thing
that always bothered me about well
they're robots those kind of books like
the rules and stuff like that it's just
it's so transactional and i was just
like dude just
be
just be just be a person and it's just
kind of like if like you meet another
person that likes like that digs
whatever your person thing is
then y'all hang out it's like don't
i don't understand like why like don't
like be
like try to put something on that you're
not i just i don't know i'm just not
down with that some people are so [ __ ]
up they have to put something on well i
get it like i get that there are some
people that really have no idea yeah
you've talked but
i don't know
i don't know it's kind of hard for me to
say look look i'm like i'm awkward too
but it's like i'm not
gonna go read a [ __ ] self-help book
tells me hey do x y z it's like that
doesn't i don't know it doesn't matter
you're well formed and organized okay
you're not like a lot of
these dudes that become in cells are
they're not normal
oh i'm not like i'm not normally either
but we're talking about the elliot
rogers says name elliot rogers
yeah that you know he still has like a
fan club like on reddit and stuff
right there's a lot of guys that
probably feel like that but
the thing is though is that you looking
at dudes like that
all right
well first of all the dude's a [ __ ]
sociopath he's a psychopath obviously
you could tell it by the by the rule and
he's on the
or he's maybe just really on the on the
autism spectrum with this sociopathy or
psychopathy might be on in the autism
spectrum i'm not sure
i don't know about it and it's not
really a science that shit's a [ __ ]
philosophy or an art anyway um no we're
gonna do a show on a dude who [ __ ]
faked him faked his way he's a german
dude sandra will love it
his name was suck him
oh [ __ ] what was his name he pretended
to be
a psychiatrist for [ __ ] years
you know right he gave whole speeches in
front of sight in the
psychiatric [ __ ]
community and they just thought he was a
genius he was a total fraud he just read
about it he had a personal grudge
because he thought psycho psychiatry
killed his mom
so he decided to become a fake
psychiatrist
and just read books on it and just
adopted their mannerisms in their in
some of their ways of uh
probably you should have come up with a
more productive like way forward we made
a [ __ ] ton of money
because he had patience and a practice
and everything and his and his patients
loved him though they said oh we got
great results from him he was a phony
total phony
uh and he would get up there and [ __ ]
tell the psychiatrist all kinds of mumbo
jumbo nonsense that he got out of books
and some of the [ __ ] was trolling them
he would troll the [ __ ] out of him on
purpose and they never called him on it
they thought he was a real psychiatrist
he was trolling
and he did it
my understanding was is that he was
doing it to undermine the psychiatric
community because he said it was all
snake oil
and he said about wanting to prove that
was snake oil it was not a science
his name was
postal
gert postal i think is what his name is
that sound familiar to you um
sandra
i'm a i'm gonna ask my local crowd i
think it was garet postal i think what
his name was
and um he's still around and he's on
twitter and he's still trolling he
trolls the [ __ ] out of [ __ ] the
psychiatric community says they're all a
bunch of frauds
but he's a uh he was a [ __ ]
professional con man made a whole bunch
of money faking it i worked in hospitals
and everything so we want to do a show
on him i think it'll be good i think
it'd be real no i i mean like i said i
have to put things in the poll i did put
a thing in the poll that was like let's
do a show about like imposters like that
guy like frank abbott like frank
abingdale like
dudes like that but i don't know we'll
see if it wins um mango says we had an
incel kill six people in the last week
here in the uk one of the victims was
three years old see this
i don't know i'm like fascinated by
dudes like that because i kind of feel
like and i don't know if this is still
the case because i feel like i read this
a long time ago so please correct me if
i'm wrong
but
i read somewhere a while back
that doing uh mris on like dudes brains
and stuff like that
apparently and like i said this is just
from memory so i don't know if this is
true we're not don't like stop it don't
happen stop it um
that when dudes
in general look at a woman
they're using the part of their brain
that they use to process objects rather
than another person like you know what i
mean like when they look at another dude
that's like a different part of the
brain that's processing that when they
look at a woman it's the part of the
brain that processes like inanimate
objects
um so i did no seriously i i you know
no i read that a while back yeah
i don't doubt it it's just you're
putting a spin on it
no i'm just saying so i wonder
if in
elliot roger type [ __ ] yeah if
this
[ __ ] is even more like pronounced
because
they seem to have this weird thing where
it's like hey i'm gonna put
you know i have a bmw i have money blah
blah i'm putting this into a vending
machine and then like a woman will come
out it's like a computer computerized
thinking yeah they do this and this and
this this then this will have to happen
but
that's not how people work though yeah
there's no soul to that guy
or personality which is like creepy but
there's like a whole [ __ ] like
sub genre of people that are like that
but um i
men looking at women if you probably
looked at their brain as you're saying
they're processing it the way they would
see an inanimate object i know exactly
what they're talking about remember i
said i look at a [ __ ] like he's
a side of beef
you said you said you look at everybody
like a side of beefy i want to see where
the muscle insertions are i want to see
the [ __ ] this and that it's kind of a
learned skill in a certain way because
you have to know what to look for
but i know dude notice that yeah you
look at women like that too
and well
it makes perfect sense because it's all
part of the animal kingdom you're sizing
up potential mates for the genetic
traits that they're carrying that's all
it is so it's not an emotional part of
your brain that's doing the computation
it's more of an analytical part you know
what i mean
how do they look what is this shape like
this and that it has nothing to do with
the woman per se
it has to do with the production of a
child
what traits will the child inherit
that's the end result it is a human
breeding prop
process birds do it you know the females
the birds do it you know what i mean
they got birds down at all the big
feathers and [ __ ] and putting on a big
old show those females are doing the
same thing they're judging hey look at
my wings yeah yeah
the children will not be viable so it
moves on
so you can't moralize
animal behavior
yeah
but on the other hand
on the other end of that though if you
are
if you are a woman yeah it is very um
alarming yeah to
know that you're being perceived that
way because you don't actually know
not alarming at all it is a lot well
you're not a woman so how would you know
well you're not you're not in the game i
guess in the right way you got to be
mentally in that groove to know what
they're doing and go yeah that's the way
it is and this is how you manipulate
that system
women do the same thing they do it
unconsciously the thing is is that women
are looking for status
they like guys who are smiling are
comfortable and they also women
gravitate towards men that other women
are smiling at
or being friendly to
and then
things start going about appearance and
how tight his appearance is the clothes
uh perceived status around them because
that means a good nest can be made and a
viable offspring will come from that
male from an alliance with that male
it's the same project it's just
different
the male doesn't have to worry about
success it's all just the physical
beauty of the female because he's got
the other [ __ ] covered
career and [ __ ] don't matter to him
yeah victor says tom's mansplaining what
women are thinking me explaining what
women are thinking well he mansplains
everything like
he's never he's never been a woman he
doesn't know how to make god
but he thinks he knows
um and i'm just not my words i'm just
going to let him think that these are
not mine because he has no idea like
what we think these are not my words
these these are the words of scientists
and sociologists that with i've [ __ ]
studied all this [ __ ]
that's how it is women gravitate towards
men that have high status they just do
like i said you're not a woman so you
don't know what women think okay so a
lot of them don't know what women so
women gravitate towards men of low
status so bums with pissed pants and
uncut hair are popular
nobody said that no they're not there's
either one or the other they either like
status or they don't no it's not they
like status women like status
that is that is a that is women are
attracted to that we're talking about
that's absolutely true low status no i'm
just saying we're not no one's saying
that everyone's males don't get you but
everyone is saying that it's very funny
i can that you think you know what women
think or attracted to i think i think
when it's actually a lot more complex
than you would have
no i'm not going to say that i'm going
to say this not complex it is complex
but i also know that women don't
actually tell the truth all the time
about the way they operate oh so now you
know when we're lying no i'm not saying
that he also knows
i know exactly what i'm talking about
okay i know exactly what i'm talking
about okay
no you don't get that good job women do
not want the beans to be spilled
high status men are always popular
they always get the top choice of mates
they just do
billionaires and [ __ ] have [ __ ] f
fantastic little wives women like them
they're successful guys they can work i
don't know if women like them they like
the money
well you may like the money you may not
be attracted to that but the women that
are attracted to them like
we're talking about averages
well like i said all right a lot of
times too like i said when she goes i'm
gonna tell you all true women are
practical
um you're like you don't like the dude
but he's got a [ __ ] ton of money he's
like yeah my life will be easier and the
kid will be fine and it's like i don't
really you know i can just like pretend
that's like the ceiling so it's like
they don't love you it's just that they
just want your money right but a lot of
times a lot of times a lot of times
those guys don't care though if the
women leave as long as they don't have
children with other men that's a lot of
a lot of those billionaires are like
that they don't give a [ __ ]
but here
here is [ __ ] some guys you can go on
derek dude from [ __ ]
uh more plays more dates
him and [ __ ]
i think there's two or three other
bodybuilders did an experiment on tinder
they put they had all these different
profiles made
okay
on one profile they had the damn
professional
[ __ ] bodybuilder shots of themselves
up there okay on that profile
that profile got a lot of views
but it didn't get very many offers from
women but the offers that it did get
were bodybuilding women
they showed their professional
um
photo shoots and [ __ ] because you know
professional
ifbb
[ __ ] bikini girls they got photo
shoots from you know bikini photo shoots
so that was that was the response that
they got from that profile
and the same dude makes another profile
under a different name
with not professional shots
but just shot to him having a good time
with his shirt on
um
or the just regular lighting
and but you you can tell that he's
jacked but it's not a [ __ ]
ultra ripped professional bodybuilder
photo shoot it's just a regular guy
who's jacked
doing regular [ __ ]
that [ __ ]
pro those profiles got the overwhelming
amount of [ __ ] views okay
and it was
um
all
attractive
females
then they would take a photograph of
themselves before they worked out they'd
make up another another profile before
they started lifting when they were you
know 18 19 20 it's the same face and
everything
but he's not ripped at all he would take
the old photos and they'd put that up
and that photo would get the responses
of nothing but just uh low estrogen
although could it be that that because
he was like much younger no it was four
of them
four different dudes
they were all professional bodybuilders
they did in a a a um
they did an experiment on tinder
using their photos of what photos
women responded to the most
before they worked out they they got no
action basically
in the professional
bodybuilders shots they got very little
action there were no mud ducks no normal
women none of them [ __ ] answered yeah
because women don't give a [ __ ] about
that no
what answer were professional
bodybuilder females and [ __ ] fitness
models
and they were also at tried to recruit
them for [ __ ] porn shoots
all right
because some of them were what do they
call them uh
instagram models
but but then the same guy jacked and
everything just in normal shots not in
professional shots overwhelmingly got
all the hits it was not only
upper echelon women but also all the
ones in the middle and that all supports
the scientific data
that 90 i think was 80 of the women are
chasing after the top 20 of the men
easily
well like i said you know it's yeah
people are going to respond more if the
only metric that you have
is a photo right people are going to
respond and like i said no one cares
about like the professional bodybuilder
shots because everybody's like okay they
do yes they do no i'm just saying i'm
just saying that that's not i'm just you
skewed that they did care
they did care who responded to that were
professional models right but
no i said in general very high echelon
but the thing is is that the same ones
that would have responded
okay all the middle ranking women that
responded to that same guy in the
non-professional photo shoot things were
also available what it is is that they
saw those photos and got intimidated
because they didn't feel that they could
keep up with that
type of guy that he looked too good
so they moved down even though it was
the same guy
it was just that he didn't look quite as
good they moved to that one it's it's
it's it makes a lot of sense when you
see the numbers and you hear what they
should they kind of explain what they
did
and in the non-professional photo shoot
ones
it was them
not jacked regular clothes
social situations smile on their faces
interacting with other people so it
looked a lot more accessible and
friendly
and they didn't look like models but
they looked jacked they were big
it is it it fits the data okay come on
let's go bro well you look like a normal
person you're not a normal person but
but it's not that nobody cared about
the professional shots it's just that it
scared a lot of a lot of them away the
only ones that weren't scared by women
that looked like that
they weren't scared by it
he thinks people are scared by this
[Laughter]
oh my god the mansplaining it's so thick
and i'm just like so drunk to like
i'm too drunk to put up with this right
now but yeah
oh my god
uh yeah let's yeah tila said what ages
would these people see that's what i'd
like to know
anyways that's victor yeah
yeah pookie came in she wanted to go
outside i don't know what time is it
okay it's not that late she can go
outside
she just goes and like sits on the fence
or sits on the porch rather
yeah it's kind of like i don't know like
i said i kind of feel like they do a lot
of these kind of
studies and there might be some merit to
them i'm sure but like i said there's a
lot of factors that they're not taking
into consideration and like i said
there's a lot of stuff that's like too
complex and honestly anytime i try to
like say anything about it he's always
like well you're different
and i'm just kind of like okay well i'm
a woman too but i guess my opinion
doesn't count so whatever
so you know what i mean no it's just
your thesis that good looking people are
not attractive that's not what i said
that is totally not what i said
holy [ __ ] you see and then he like says
[ __ ] that i didn't even say
because
people are attractive because you're
hearing things that i'm not saying okay
i didn't i didn't say that maybe i maybe
i didn't understand you i didn't
understand what you meant you obviously
didn't no i obviously didn't the photos
and the responses on
because is that good looking people are
attractive
the better looking you are the less
responses you will get but the higher
quality the better looking the people
that do respond to it but everybody
knows that already i'm just saying and
that's not what i said okay so the thing
about well i think the problem is that
you don't really listen to what i say
you just hear
what you want to hear you said nobody
cared about those guys that look like
that no i'm just saying that no i'm just
saying that it's like that's not really
what people if you put up okay if you
put a photo up of yourself and you're
all like jacked and everything and you
put a photo of yourself in your little
like speedos or whatever and you're like
posing like that you put a photo like
that in your dating profile that's not
what they put though everyone's gonna
say no i'm just saying in general if you
did that everybody was like oh jesus
christ
everyone just roll their eyes
that's not what they put though they put
really [ __ ] good like high quality
artistic photographs like black and
whites with the shadows it looked like
stuff like on heavy metal posters it
looked it looked pretty good looked like
something out of a movie again that
seems like a little much it seems a
little try hard uh no
the responses that those got were like i
said other ifbb pro bodybuilder women uh
only fans models and stuff like that
wanted to know if they wanted to do
photo shoots together and [ __ ] like that
and new seats
other people the female equivalent of
that responded and they had those same
kind of
you
photos
what i mean like because they knew what
it was that they were looking at
yeah but like i said that's kind of well
it's like it was goths it's like well
yeah it's like that's what i was just
gonna say it's like a niche market right
right you're just gonna like attract
people
but that same guy who might repel a
person who feels like that that's out of
reach
in just a normal shot was overwhelmingly
popular
you know what i mean a problem
and i think we've talked about this
before but another problem that a lot of
goth chicks have in particular not so
much goth dudes but goth chicks in
particular have if you have a profile
picture that looks gothy in any way
uh you know you're going to get like
goth dudes and they have like some [ __ ]
in common with you and stuff but you're
also going to get a a insubstantial
amount of normal ass people that just
see you as a fetish and think that you
have something in common with them and
say well i don't even think i don't even
think they give a [ __ ] about that i kind
of feel like oh you look like that so
you must be like uh a freak so you must
be into like all this weird ass [ __ ] and
i'm just like oh teach me your ways like
you're all into like s m and stuff so i
kind of feel like there's a contingent
of people and i don't think it's as bad
as it used to be
but you still get it every now and then
like when you're out at the club and
not so much at you know places where
it's just mostly gots but if you go to
places where normal people are you still
kind of get like people that are just
like hey
you like drinking blood blood it's like
you get that kind of crap so
i i kind of feel like that's why a lot
of people that are into like the goth
sub culture that's why there's whole
like
there's whole dating sites like for
god's only because you don't want
all these normal because it's it's uh
you know they fetishize
the thing because they think that you're
into like you you're gonna like whip
them and stuff and they want to do that
and you know i don't know it's like this
whole thing but um so i feel like i feel
like that kind of [ __ ] is going on
because it's like it's a subculture
just like bodybuilding for example is a
subculture so i feel like people that
are also into that subculture obviously
are going to be more interested in you
because like hey here's something like i
share an interest with this person yeah
goes tom how do you know it wasn't all
fakes or clicks and views but no that
wasn't what it was okay it was just
you can find the conversation it's on
more plates more dates and they i can't
remember the exact video it was but it
was four guys on there they're all ifbb
pro well not all of them but they're all
pro level in terms of like bodybuilding
all right including
including um derek
they just did an experiment all four of
them
on tinder
with their photos
they made different profiles
for themselves that's a very small
sample size that was just four guys but
they wanted to see what photos women
responded to most
the ones that they responded to most
in terms of just sheer numbers okay
was the ones of just them normal hanging
out talking and [ __ ]
but they you could tell that he was that
they were strong kind of muscular guys
they were all good-looking guys
um
the ones before they were working out
and it must have been working out you
know five years or so
didn't get hardly any action because
they looked very average
um the one the professional ones though
um only got responses from
like i said professional bodybuilder
women and professional models that's the
only thing that responds well and let me
let me throw this at you too
um
as far as and this is again a
generalization as far as dating websites
or that type of thing goes
women on dating websites
do not generally
uh contact men
usually it's the other way around like
because
the thing about it women on dating sites
no matter what they look like
usually get a bunch of trolls uh you get
a bunch of messages from weirdos
you get like [ __ ] [ __ ] all day long
so
so a lot of women are like reluctant to
so there's actually a very very small
subset of women that are on dating sites
that will actually like even message a
man
unprovoked yeah well they didn't they
didn't say they didn't mention in the
conversation from i remember
they didn't say who initiated contact it
could have been that they were
initiating the contact that's what i'm
saying because women who responded women
in general they said it was not initiate
content and like i said not everybody
because some of them do it depends on
the site but a lot of women do not
initiate contact on dating sites because
of the amount of trolls and weirdos and
creeps and [ __ ] like that all they've
said not seen anything revolutionary
some people are like no need for me
going like dude well of course or
attracted people are [ __ ] attractive
they get attractive [ __ ] action
what it is is they just confirmed from
their experience in general from their
experience it matched up with the data
that what was it
80 of the women are [ __ ] running
after the top 20 of the guys although 80
percent of how many well you know that's
just more they talk about in terms of
volume
oh in the dating population
um that average
average guys really kind of get
neglected what got most of the [ __ ]
action was guys that were in the top 20
at least if they were [ __ ] really
good looking only models and [ __ ]
responded to it even though it was the
same guy and it was just based upon but
the same thing happens with women i
don't know how's the women exactly
you know what i mean i mean in general
like i said this is a generalization
because
it's just like the goth chicks with the
fantastic photo shoots
just exactly the same
that's what all that that was all this
was about i'm not saying that i'm wrong
or you're right i was saying that
men and women are doing the same thing
although like i said a lot of times
it's hard to extrapolate with
men's data because women don't usually
initiate contact with dudes on dating
sites because
they have too much especially if the
woman is
i understand i understand if the woman
is in any way attractive
she has messages and creeps and [ __ ]
like that all day long so it's like
she's not gonna
initiate because it's like you don't
know that you could be [ __ ] ted
i'm assuming based on what they said and
i remembered they were going by who
responded so they were probably going
out and actually initiating the con
initiating the contact and they got
these numbers based on what females and
what does respond mean started talking
and wanting to date and or wanting to
meet or that kind of thing or you know
that's probably what they're talking
about they were just saying whatever got
the most
traffic whoever you know i mean what was
most useful you know
in terms of volume just the numbers of
them it was good looking guy without
professional photo shoots
in natural settings
shown shown in groups where he's getting
along with other people so so he's a
real person
well yeah
well that's good
that overwhelmingly got the most of them
but when it turned when it came into
like the best looking ones it was the uh
the best looking women that were that
responded and were interested or
whatever was the ones from the
professional shoots it's because they
had those professional shoots too
it'd be like me with [ __ ] gothed out
[ __ ] photo shoots and then [ __ ]
some chick was the goth out photo shoot
responded that's all well like i said
that at that point it's like a
subculture that exactly exactly you know
so so that can't be generalized to the
course
generalized because what it means is it
means is a
non-bodybuilder woman is going to look
at a bodybuilder guy and go nah no
thanks
that's what it means well that's all i
was saying earlier and you yelled at me
like i was wrong no
yeah you did you said no one was
interested not no one other body but
that's what i meant obviously but then
you take that same guy and just change
the photographs and all of a sudden
she's interested
because you don't look like you're just
like hey look at me
you don't look like that nobody likes an
attention [ __ ]
that's all i'm saying well they have
those they have those professional shots
done and for a lot of reasons some of
those shits for [ __ ] promotions for
further right i get that um but you
don't put that on your dating profile
because that's that would be like super
power you would if you that would be
super try hard you would if you're a pro
bodybuilder if you were trying to get
another bodybuilder then it would work
then okay but if you were just trying to
like you know find somebody in the
general population
then don't do that because it's try hard
and most people would be like you still
liked that guy though no thanks they
still liked that guy because they
responded to that same guy because
honestly if i was on a dating site and i
saw that i'd be like oh jesus christ
[Laughter]
i've seen some pretty cool photo shoots
of [ __ ] male and female bodybuilders
i could show them to the camera right
now they're not that ridiculous you know
what i mean [ __ ] they have real art
decorations they say they were
ridiculous i'm just saying that it's
like it's just looks cool just be normal
it's just that is normal though because
no but
if you're
no i'm saying that if you're on a dating
site looking for something that you're
going to date and potentially this is
like a long-term thing you want a normal
person you don't want an image you know
what i'm saying and so that's what i
mean by tryhard you're trying to portray
this image this is my professional look
i'm just like all this and whatever it
is it's like
whether you're like an instagram model
or whatever it's like you want something
that looks like you're a normal person
because that's
who you're going to be dating
you're not going to be dating a picture
of that person if you put if you put up
there i'm i'm i'm kind of
uh whatever if you put up a profile
saying look my name is [ __ ] something
rather i'm an ifbb [ __ ] pro
bodybuilder and this is me and this is
what i do and blah blah blah and i'm
looking you know and i'm looking for a
special woman and he hears me in this i
i don't think that that's try hard at
all because that's who that dude is it'd
be like saying i'm a professional race
car driver and this and that well no but
what did i just say i just said if
that's the market that you're targeting
that is who you resist that's the
response but if you're trying to
you know if you're trying to market
yourself to like a wider audience
you know you're just looking for
somebody that isn't a bodybuilder or
isn't like their whole life isn't
revolving around that i don't know what
do you guys think then what do you guys
think then i wouldn't advise it to me
it's all circling because like i said
it's all circular logic because like i
said
it's kind of like it's almost kind of
like putting up here's photos of me at
work but that's like all you're putting
up
it's just kind of one it seems try hard
and two it's just kind of like i'm not
seeing you
as a normal person like where's the
photos of you like hanging out with your
friends or just like doing normal [ __ ]
which is what you would do if you were
dating that person so i kind of feel
like if you're making a dating profile
that's not the same thing
as doing like an instagram [ __ ] you know
what i'm saying those are two different
things uh top echelon goth check it's a
different audience a top echelon goth
chick on a [ __ ] dating site if she
were to go on one would put her [ __ ]
photo shoot photos up there
because that's the one that they put up
on facebook that's what they would put
there it's a double standard
it's not though because like i said it's
i it's it's also annoying when chicks do
that yeah because it's like look i know
you don't look like that really yeah um
so that's that that there's whole
profile and i'm not saying that you have
to put up like photos of yourself
looking like [ __ ] like oh hey i just got
out of bed i'm not saying that everybody
wants to put their best foot forward i
get that you don't have to put up like
photos of yourself hey look i have the
flu yeah tina's got it right people need
to get off their asses and meet people
the old-fashioned way enough these sites
that's true
that's what i mean because there's just
too much
that's why i don't really like it you
don't i mean i don't know if you don't
know a person you meet in a bar either
it's like they could be like they they
could look super good in the bar
in the dark when you're drunk and then
you get home and like you have sex with
that person the next morning you're like
oh well okay well that was a mistake
yeah no you know what i mean no fours
with tens that's what i'm saying yeah
right
all right well i don't know about you
but i'm getting i'm getting kind of
tired of the show i'm going to get
something to eat
what is that stuff done what's that oh
yeah it's done it's got to heat it back
up what are you going to do with it
maybe make some mashed potatoes want
some potatoes with it or rice
[ __ ] rice i want mashed potatoes okay i
can do that i'm not a big race fan
you know what i'm saying yeah
all right let's watch a movie like what
i don't know we'll see something
wait when i we'll find some it's not
just turning nine right
it's not even it's 8 25. did you let
pookie go outside yeah i gotta get her
bring her i brought her uh set her out
about 15 minutes ago does she have her
clothes on yep
okay okay we're so funny well does she
have her clothes on yeah the coffee it's
her collar
[Laughter]
all right well it's been another good
show [ __ ] talking with you guys um
[ __ ] we've been on for nearly three
hours no uh three hours and 31 minutes
yeah see she's gonna disconnect three
hours all right three thousand well no
i'm just telling you it's right there
how long you've been live okay i know
you can't take strong i can't say i'm
glasses that's all just blurry
well yeah it is for me too that's why i
wear glasses right he's too vain to wear
glasses no i put glasses on when i try
to read but that's still too far away
yeah three hours 31 minutes 58 seconds
actually now three hours 32 seconds all
right
but yeah so thanks everybody for hanging
out with us
on this wednesday night
this is kind of fun yeah i had a fun
show yeah what the [ __ ] do we even yeah
it's great what did we talk about the
whole time [ __ ] [ __ ] come up with
a come up with a title for me because i
was like i usually do like a like a
title when i first put the stream up and
i'm just like i don't know what we're
going to talk about so i just ufos
i put stream ufos i put tacky
[Laughter]
so i have to like come up with like a
better type of tacky alien pretty people
versus ugly people
okay that's uh
that'll be good i think that'll be long
enough so i'll come up with something
because i'm going to come up with like
some picture to like [ __ ] put on
instagram
oh uh a [ __ ] sandra's true form
[Laughter]
sandra's boss okay
i'm gonna [ __ ] hand out that girl's
porn name so you guys [ __ ] i'm gonna
give a hand out sandra's porn name so
y'all can [ __ ] jerk to it and [ __ ]
that's you sandra
yeah yeah she goes it looks just like me
except the face the hair the nose
i love that
[Laughter]
just came off the top of my head pat
says has it really been that long it
doesn't seem like it a testament to how
interesting you guys are well thank you
very much it honestly doesn't seem like
that long to us either probably because
we've been drinking and also we're just
like we're bullshitting like we always
do so you know but yeah so uh we'll be
back friday night we're gonna be talking
about
munchausen syndrome yeah which i feel
like i forgot like i put this in the
poll and then it won and i was kind of
like oh wait a minute i think this kind
of like won one of the or tied with one
of the polls and we talked about on the
side track show so i think we talked
about like a case of munchausen by proxy
uh on the side tracks a long time ago
but
whatever [ __ ] it we're just gonna like
talk about it again on friday nights
we're gonna i found some like different
cases of it we're gonna like talk about
it camp guy said i can't remember my
first podcast here yeah well you know
aliens and tangents this whole [ __ ]
show is tangents sold so it was a [ __ ]
show
but this whole show is a [ __ ] show
[Laughter]
but that's what's fun about it though
it's fun we're like arguing about it
this way you and that porn shift are
shared 99.99 of look at the same dna
see how do you feel about that
how would tom look with big giant
boobies i don't know
let's go to that let's go to photoshop
and find out see what happens
it's like [ __ ] sanders talking all
that [ __ ] over the times about [ __ ]
titties flapping in the wind and just
all these [ __ ] games you've been
playing and the whole time
that's who i was associating with this
is a [ __ ] at that [ __ ] right there
cause i it's that girl's famous i just
forgot what her name was she's just
german she's a german model
yeah this is i bet you that's that [ __ ]
right there i don't remember her name
though
that'd be funny if that was her
[Laughter]
i'm sure it's not i mean that would
really be
yeah it was the only german model that
came to mind
with boobs and [ __ ]
[ __ ]
see this is this is the thought that's
the thought process that goes through
yeah
i mean you can pretty much guess it's
it's not real hard to figure out
oh my god just think of it
all right so yeah we'll be back um i'm
gonna put up a video tomorrow but
we'll be back friday night talking about
munchausen syndrome that should be a fun
show at least it's not i mean that's
kind of like depressing topic but at
least it's not like serial killers i did
a much housing one already well i told
you what did i just say five minutes ago
less than five minutes ago yes see he
doesn't listen i do what i wanted to
but how frustrating is to have to like
repeat everything so many times because
you don't listen the first time i was
probably passing out man i'm [ __ ]
saying no you weren't what did i just
say five minutes ago i said we talked
about munchausen syndrome on a side
track show yeah that's right a while
back yeah i guess so but it won in the
poll anyway
so we're doing like a dedicated show
repetitive man no they're not okay
everybody was just like interesting so
you know what i mean
victor says her name is hilda wolffe
schlegen steinhausen
yeah yeah that's her real name yesterday
that's her name that's one thing i was
admired about german it's like you know
what it's just we're gonna like we're
gonna just keep adding syllables man
we're just gonna have this big yeah just
keep adding the words well it's you know
and they have this one word is this long
yeah and you know we'll get across the
whole entire concept with this one word
that's like 50 feet long
yeah i like that i like your game
germany
old farm girls down there
farm boys with the [ __ ] blowing [ __ ]
[ __ ] drinking status dines and stuff
sure up in the mountains
with their lederhosen
sorry i just thought if i thought of
national leopoon's european vacation
without all the leaders and those
slapping each other
i don't know why that just occurred to
me yeah yeah it's my own i got a feeling
i got a feeling i got to feel sandra's a
city girl
yeah
all right so
yeah we're gonna go eat okay and then uh
we'll be back friday night talking about
munches and syndrome thank you everybody
for dropping by thanks for super chats
thanks for the discussion this was a
super fun show yeah t decided to show up
today normally she hasn't been showing
up that [ __ ] playing truancy with me
man she's getting through it hey maybe
she has better things to do did you ever
think of that maybe no you never thought
of that did you all right so she's
starring on this [ __ ] man
we're gonna have to like make shirts for
every single one of like the regulars
i'm telling you man you need to get the
[ __ ] you need to get the dab software
set up that they could call in and we'll
put them up on a little box and [ __ ] i'm
thinking about like i don't know how how
is the best way to like do this i don't
know i'll figure it out one of these
days have tina call in and have her up
there on a little [ __ ] square
yeah i can talk to her i'd say all kinds
of crazy [ __ ] but she's funny because
you know she types funny
let's see if she can deliver live on the
air you type funny yeah you tired for me
not unless round is funny yeah we'll put
we'll put sandra up there we'll [ __ ]
see what her accent sounds like
[Laughter]
and then tom will just like accent and
then tom will just make fun of you no
it's probably cute
but he'll make fun of you yeah
all right
so we'll be back friday night
uh you know thanks everybody for
stopping by thanks for super chats like
i said thanks for hanging out with us on
this wednesday and getting drunk with us
it's always super fun we will see you
guys on friday evening
bye